Wir wollen blicken auf den europäischen Fußball heute in einer etwas kleineren Runde, als ihr es uns gewohnt seid. Mit Christian Bernhard sprechen wir über die Serie A, mit Jakob Haffke über die Liga und mit Chris McCarthy über die Premier League. Und genau jetzt geht's los. Und nun im Programm, der Rasenfunk.
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Es fühlt sich an, als hätte ich dieses Intro gerade erst gehört. Aber das muss eine Illusion sein. Ihr drei, schön, dass ihr hier seid. Schönen guten Morgen.
Hallo. Guten Morgen.
In welch wunderbarer Qualität ich euch höre. Aber ich wüsste nicht, warum das bemerkenswert sein sollte. Ihr habt es gehört, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, heute eine etwas kleinere Runde. Aber das macht es ja nicht minder interessant. Und wir haben, Christian, wenn wir gleich mal mit dir beginnen, ja auch mindestens ein Thema in der Serie A, das auch gerade eine hohe Relevanz hat für viele Fans des deutschen Fußballs. Wir wollen mal über Atalanta sprechen, die ja mit 4 zu 1 den BVB rausgenommen haben aus der Champions League. Wer das nicht mitbekommen hat, hat unter einem Stein gelebt und die jetzt dann auch der nächste Gegner vom FC Bayern sind. Auf was können sich denn die Bayern da gefasst machen?
Ja, ich wollte eben aufgrund dieser Konstellation, vielleicht lohnt es sich mal ein bisschen tiefgründiger draufzuschauen. Ich würde mal so anfangen, ich war etwas überrascht teilweise über die Bewertung einiger Deutsch- oder Sportmedien. Ich habe da so Begriffe wie Blamage und so gelesen nach dem Ausscheiden von Dortmund. Das fand ich jetzt ein bisschen, wenn man sich Atalanta die letzten Jahre angeschaut hat, weiß ich nicht, ob man da nach dem Ausscheiden gegen Atalanta von einer Blamage sprechen sollte. Aber das nur mal so als als Nebenaspekt. Ja, was erwartet die Bayern oder was zeigt Atalanta? Ich wollte mal eigentlich ein bisschen drauf eingehen, was die ja seit, was wir hier auch schon immer wieder mal ein, zwei Mal angerissen haben, wie gut einfach der Unterbau von Atalanta ist, dass so was eben sozusagen immer wieder auch passieren kann. Also Atalanta war ja auch, hatte ja im Sommer diesen riesen Umbruch nach neun Jahren Gasperini, was logisch ein riesen Schritt war. Dann kam Juric und das hat man schnell gesehen, dass das ja nicht so funktioniert hat. Der Punkt ist der, rückblickend sagen jetzt manche in Italien auch, wenn Palladino gleich im Sommer übernommen hätte, wer weiß, was da gewesen wäre. Ich glaube, dass es gar nicht so schlecht war, sowohl für Verein als auch vielleicht für Palladino selbst, dass da so ein bisschen eben dieser Break dazwischen war, weil diese Legacy von Gasperini direkt zu übernehmen. Also ich weiß nicht, ob das reibungslos gleich eins zu eins weitergegangen wäre. Also Atalanta hat in dem Fall eine schnelle Entscheidung getroffen, gemerkt, dass das mit Juric einfach nicht funktioniert. Und worauf ich ihm hinaus wollte, diese Überraschung, die teilweise in Deutschland da war. Also Atalanta hat auch in der Saison, die waren bis zum letzten Champions League Hauptrundenspieltag im Rennen, um die Top 8, also um die direkte Achtelfinalqualifikation. Und sie haben unter anderem in der Hauptrunde auch Chelsea geschlagen und Marseille auswärts. Also trotz dieses nicht mehr oder nach plus eins oder halt wie soll man sagen, Gasparini vorbei und logisch einige Fragezeichen haben sie ja trotzdem wieder europäisch sehr schnell in die Spur gefunden. Und deswegen wollte ich ein bisschen darauf blicken, dass Atalanta halt seit Jahren eben sozusagen eine unfassbar gute Basis legt. Also Atalanta wird im Sommer, hat jetzt den 10., die 10. positive Bilanz in Serie eingefahren. Also wirtschaftlich steht das einfach auf wahnsinnig guten Füßen. Atalanta hat das Stadion, das jetzt hier umgebaut wurde, hat da 100 Millionen Euro in die Hand genommen. Das ist wirklich sehr viel Geld, gerade in Italien, wo man das ja kennt, wo lieber historisch gesehen dann nochmal in zwei, drei Spieler mehr investiert wird, als vielleicht in Infrastruktur. Hat Atalanta allein da, was das Stadion betrifft, sehr viel Geld in die Hand genommen. Nicht nur das Stadion, sondern auch das Trainingszentrum in Singonia. Da wurden auch 30 Millionen investiert. Und das ist jetzt wirklich eines der modernsten in ganz Europa. Also da gibt es wirklich auch Beobachter, internationale Beobachter, die das sehr loben, was Atalanta eben auch drum herum sozusagen gebaut hat. Wenn man sich dann auch die Transfers anschaut, im Winter zum Beispiel hatten wir hier auch kurz angerissen, wurde dann Lugman verkauft und zwar für 40 Millionen Euro. Der in eineinhalb Jahren wäre der Vertrag ausgelaufen, also jetzt nicht im Sommer 2026, sondern 2027. Und im Prinzip war klar, das wird nicht mehr langfristig weitergehen. Lugman war ja schon im vergangenen Sommer die Nummer, dass er ein bisschen weg wollte, diesen Sprung machen wollte. Und am Ende hat Atalanta ihn nicht an Inter verkauft im vergangenen Sommer, weil der Preis einfach nicht, den sie ausgerufen hatten, gezahlt wurde. Und jetzt haben sie ihn ungefähr für die Sommer verkauft, nämlich 40 plus x, die sie auch im Sommer wollten. Nur hat Lugman ja eigentlich seit einem halben Jahr relativ wenig gespielt, eben immer wieder Trainingsrückstand gehabt, dann Afrika Cup. Also auch hier sieht man die Stärke des Klubs, sozusagen, dann nur zu seinen Konditionen zu verkaufen. Und genau, das wollte ich mal so ein bisschen vielleicht einordnen. Und der letzte Punkt, bevor ich euch gerne mit reinhole, man sieht halt auch die Jugendarbeit. Also gegen Dortmund ist vielleicht einigen, der Name wird wahrscheinlich den wenigsten was gesagt haben, Lorain Zubernasconi, der Mann auf der linken Schiene, der linke Außenverteidiger. Das ist halt einer von, weiß nicht wie vielen in den letzten Jahren, die aus der eigenen Jugend kommen, die in der Atalanta U23 gespielt haben. Da ist Atalanta aber auch einer der ersten Klubs in Italien, die eben diese zweite Mannschaft jetzt haben, die in der dritten Liga spielt. Der hat letztes Jahr 27 oder 30 Pflichtspiele gemacht, hat sich da so ein bisschen den Profi-Schliff, sag ich mal, geholt und Spielzeit dieser Saison hat jetzt die linke Seite nicht mehr abgegeben, hat auch von Anfang an auch unter Juric, da muss man wirklich auch Juric noch hervorheben, Juric hat ihn auch Anfang der Saison schon immer in der Champions League spielen lassen, also da wird den Jungen halt eben auch das Vertrauen gegeben, diese größeren Spiele zu spielen und Einnahme, der jetzt im Moment gar nicht bei Atalanta ist, aber der eigentlich in Italien die Schlagzeilen jetzt schon seit Monaten bestimmt, das ist Marco Palestra von Caliari, das ist der gleiche Spielertyp nur für die rechte Seite, also rechte Schiene oder rechter Außenverteidiger, der ist ausgeliehen an Caliari, der ist der Aufsteiger der Saison in Italien, der kommt im Sommer zurück, weil er wirklich nur eine reine Laie ist, also da hat auch Caliari gar keine Option, da geht es jetzt darum, da sind alle großen Italiener auch schon große Engländer dran, den werden wir wahrscheinlich jetzt schon Ende März in den Playoffs im Nationaltrikot sehen, vielleicht wenn Gattur so mutig ist, spielt er sogar Stamm schon jetzt in den Playoff-Spielen. Und da sieht man eben, was Atalanta Jahr für Jahr drum herum schon im Hintergrund wieder sich hinlegt, quasi um diese Geschichte in den nächsten Jahren weiterzuschreiben.
Ja, man muss eben sagen, neben dem, was man so sportlich auch so mitverfolgt hat, mit dem eigenen Stil und mit den ersten Erfolgen, die ja noch schwerer zu fassen sind, wenn man sich ein bisschen mit der Geschichte von Atalanta beschäftigt, kommt ja mit dazu eben das Wirtschaftliche, was du angesprochen hast, was aber ja darauf gefußt hat, dass man jetzt im Grunde in jedem Transferfenster einen großen Abgang hatte. Also zum Beispiel Retegi haben wir jetzt ja, also haben wir schon mal angesprochen in der Ligatour, das haben wir jetzt gar nicht genannt, der hat viel Geld gebracht, Coop Miners zu Juve in der Vorsaison, dann Heulund zu United davor und davor dann Romero zu.
Romero, ja.
Ich hab ihn ein bisschen schnell drüber gelesen. Also das ist eben das, was quasi wirtschaftlich immer wieder Atalanta befähigt, zum einen viele Spieler so in der 20 Millionen Euro Region zu holen, so rund, jetzt mal so ungefähr gerundet, hätte ich gesagt. Und das eben dann auch in Infrastruktur und so weiter zu stecken. Aber mich würde mal interessieren, was ihr anderen beiden sagt. Jakob, Chris, Blamage vom BVB. Also ich verstehe total deinen Punkt, Christian. Ich glaube, das ist aber halt so komplett aus der deutschen Sicht gesehen, wenn du mit einem 2 zu 0 hingehst und dann eben 1 zu 4 mit der roten Karte und so weiter. Wahrscheinlich kam es daher. Also habt ihr euch darüber auch, habt ihr das manchmal auch, dass es quasi wenn es um Liga-Vereine oder Premier League-Vereine geht, dass ihr das Gefühl habt, ja, das ist halt so irgendwie so eine ganz komische Sicht auf andere Ligen?
Ja, schon. Also gerade, ich weiß jetzt nicht, in Bezug auf die Premier League so ist, aber abgesehen davon habe ich schon das Gefühl, dass man, wenn es nicht der größte Verein aus dem Land ist, dass man dann häufig die Teams unterschätzt bzw. vielleicht auch die Qualität der Bundesliga einfach überschätzt.
Ja, das sehe ich ähnlich und ich finde, man hat auch, man merkt auch in den letzten Jahren ist das auch so ein Thema gewesen. Ich sage mal, als der Aufschwung von Arsenal wieder begann beispielsweise und Arsenal jetzt in den letzten Jahren zum ersten Mal wieder auf Bayern in der Champions League traf, nach langjähriger Abzinenz, da wurde auch immer gesagt, ach Arsenal, die hat man ja immer 5-1 abgeschossen, das wird ein leichtes Los und da hat man so richtig gemerkt, man ist auf einem Strand von vor zehn Jahren beispielsweise und nicht jeder kriegt die aktuellen Entwicklungen immer in den Ligen mit und vieles ist dann auf Vorurteile geprägt oder historische Sachen geprägt und ja, das war das fand ich damals ziemlich auffällig.
Weil alle zu wenig Ligatour.
Ja, das kann man sowieso generell immer sagen, außer diejenigen, die das jetzt hier hören. Ihr seid nicht gemeint, aber euer Umfeld zum Beispiel ist wahrscheinlich schon größtenteils mit gemeint. Ja, aber ich stelle die Frage natürlich auch deshalb, weil Christian, das ist einem ja auch nach der Auslosung für den FC Bayern aufgefallen, da habe ich dann manchmal sogar gelesen, das leichteste Los, gut, es waren jetzt nur zwei Möglichkeiten, Leverkusen oder Atalanta, wo ich sagen würde, also ich gucke sehr viel Leverkusen und ganz wenig Atalanta. Deswegen finde ich Leverkusen aber gerade nicht so prall, ehrlich gesagt. Aber es scheint sich ja schon wieder so fortzusetzen. Glaubst du, dass das vielleicht auch die Chance von Atalanta ist, wie in der Vergangenheit ja manchmal auch? Man wird schon eher notorisch unterschätzt.
Ja, wobei ich jetzt glaube, durch dieses Dortmund-Ding, glaube ich, ist jetzt gerade zumindest im Bayern-Umfeld, glaube ich, sind die Sinne schon sehr geschärft. Also, ich glaube, den Bayern-Umfeld würde ich das jetzt nicht unterstellen, dass sie die unterschätzen. Mir ging es ja auch darum, nur noch einen Satz dazu zu feuern. Klar hätte Dortmund da auch weiterkommen können, gar keine Frage. So wie das Rückspiel jetzt auch lief, mir geht es ja nicht darum zu sagen, dass der Atalanta weiterkommen musste. Mein Empfinden war nur, auch ein Hinspiel 2 zu 0. Ja, das ist ein nettes Polster, aber ein 2 zu 0 in der K.O.-Phase nehme ich jetzt nicht wie ein 4-0 oder ein 5-0 im Hinspiel war, wo ich da würde ich dann auch sagen, ok, da musst du weiterkommen. Das ist nur, um die Klammer zu schließen. Klar wird Atalanta gegen Bayern auch der Underdog sein. Ich glaube auch, dass Bayern zu stabil in dieser Saison ist, zu gut. Aber worauf ich hinaus wollte, ist eben, Atalanta schafft es auch immer wieder so, diese Energie nochmal aufzuwenden. Deswegen glaube ich schon, es ist jetzt auch einfach so, aus Atalantas Sicht so ein riesen Bonus-Spiel. Also die wissen ganz genau, das logisch ist Bayern der große Favorit und die werden halt wieder alles probieren, da sozusagen gerade im Hinspiel im Bergamo, in diesem heimischen Umfeld, das ist kein großes Stadion, aber da kann eine besondere Energie entstehen, da halt erstmal eine gute Figur abzugeben und dann schauen, was geht. Wie gesagt, sie sind halt einfach, würde ich sagen, europäisch schon gestellt die letzten Jahre. Ich meine, dieser Europa League Sieg, der geht vielleicht auch bei ein paar Beobern Macht mal unter, weil das war ein Europa League Sieg, der eher Richtung, das war mehr als eine normale Europa League. Die haben in der Einfühltod gegen das Klopp Liverpool in der Prime gewonnen. Die haben Leverkusen, die ungeschlagen waren, geschlagen. Ich glaube, die haben Marseille auch rausgenommen, oder? Jakob, hilf mir damals, glaube ich, in der K.O.-Phase. Also Atalanta hat jetzt schon über Jahre gezeigt, dass sie europäisch, gerade wenn diese Champions League Musik angeht und diese europäischen Arbeide da sind, ja schon eine gewisse Energie entstehen kann. Und da vielleicht nur noch ein, zwei Namen, weil das finde ich auch das Besondere an Atalanta. Wir reden da halt über den Mix. Ich habe jetzt gesagt, Bernas Koni, die Jungen, Karne Sekhi muss man nennen, der logischerweise also mittlerweile für mich, was der in der Saison noch mal draufgepackt hat, mit in der Serie A, mit der beste Torhüter ist. Der auch zum Beispiel, kleine Klammer auf und zu. Inter und Juwe werden im Sommer auf der Torhüterposition was tun. Aber ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass wir keine Säcke im Atalanta-Trikot sehen werden. Weil die den nicht verkaufen müssten. Ganz einfach. Und der wird so ein teures Preisschild kriegen, dass ich glaube, dass weder Inter noch Juwe das hinlegen könnten. Das ist jetzt einfach mal eine Vermutung von mir. Also auch da, Atalanta hat dann halt einfach nicht den Namen, dabei nicht bei euch. Logisch haben sie nicht den Namen von Inter, Juwe, Milan. Aber sie haben mittlerweile die Gemengelage oder die, wie sagt man, die Basis geschaffen, trotzdem mit den großen Italienern mithalten zu können. Genau. Und der letzte Satz, ich finde dieser Mix aus, du hast die Jungen, die aus der eigenen Jugend kommen, die immer wieder da reinwachsen. Und dann hast du halt so Figuren wie Deron, wie Jim City, wie Baselic, die halt seit Jahren dabei sind, die wirklich teilweise fast diesen ganzen Weg mit Gasperini gegangen sind und immer noch eine tragende Rolle spielen. Also das sind ja keine Mitläufer. Gerade Baselic, das ist echt eine schöne Geschichte. Vielleicht die letzte da noch. Von dem ist vor ein paar Wochen der Vater gestorben. Das war wahnsinnig emotional. Und der hat jetzt gegen Dortmund getroffen. Der hat jetzt gestern der Coppa Italia getroffen im Halbfinale-Hinspiel. Er hat jetzt gegen Napoli auch das Spiel vor kurzem, kurz vorm Dortmundspiel entschieden. Der ist jetzt mittlerweile der Mittelfeldspieler, der Serie A, ausländische Mittelfeldspieler mit den meisten Toren in der Geschichte. Also wenn man nur Mittelfeldspieler hernimmt. Der hat jetzt 50 plus, das Mittelfeldspieler, wie gesagt. Der hat gegen Dortmund auf der Doppel-6 gespielt. Klar, der hat manchmal auch falsche 10, falsche 9 gespielt, weil er ein sehr dynamischer, auch auf offensiveren Positionen ist. Aber der hat jetzt Milinkovic Savic von Lazio überholt. Und der ist halt ein Garant. Von dem kriegst du jedes Jahr deine 6, 7, 8, 9. Einmal hat er sogar 14 Tore geschossen. Und der ist halt auch schon ewig dabei. Und das finde ich so das Schöne, dass du, dass es Atalanta irgendwie immer wieder schafft, wie du es ja auch beschrieben hast, über diese großen Transfers, sich ein bisschen selbst neu zu erfinden. Und aber trotzdem immer halt diesen harten Kern, der mitgeht. Und deswegen finde ich das wirklich eine schöne europäische Fußballgeschichte.
Und irgendwie ist es auch schön, dass man so genau weiterverfolgen kann, dadurch, dass es halt der Gegner von einem deutschen Team ist. Das mag ich irgendwie immer dann. Ehrlich gesagt, für mich ist das oft so der Abgleich mit dem, was ihr mir schon alles erzählt habt. Dann sehe ich es mal selber und denke so, ach krass, hatten mal wieder alle recht. Okay, gut zu wissen. Also Atalanta, wir schauen es uns natürlich weiter an. Wir haben jetzt auch schon ein bisschen, Chris, über die Premier League gesprochen, indirekt und mit Arsenal. Und das, was sich bei Arsenal verändert hat, was nicht jeder mitbekommen hat, auch indirekt auch schon über dein Thema. Du hast dir wieder ein wunderschönes Überthema ausgesucht. Worum geht es denn?
Ja, den hässlichen Trend in der Premier League, nämlich Standards. Hässlich natürlich, Anführungszeichen. Ja, die Premier League, nicht nur Arsenal, erlebt in dieser Saison wirklich einen Trend, der dahingeht, sich sehr, sehr, sehr auf Standards zu fokussieren. 28 Prozent der Tore fallen auf Standards. Das ist der höchste Wert seit 2009. Serie A ist bei 24, Bundesliga bei 22, Ligue 1 bei 17. Also Jakob sieht am meisten Spielfluss. Tore aus dem Spielhaus.
Ja, oder die schlechtesten Ecken. Das kann auch sein.
Ich wollte es schön ausdrücken. Und ja, La Liga 19 Prozent, um das noch abzurunden. Und wir sind auch nur bei 1,8 Toren aus dem Spielhaus pro Spiel. Das ist der niedrigste Wert seit 2015. Klar, Arsenal ist hier der Primus mit 16 Eckballtoren. Das ist der Rekord, ist bereits eingestellt. Sieben Spiele vor Schluss, also da kann jetzt noch mal ausgebaut werden. Und ja, man sieht alleine schon an der Tatsache, dass Nicolas Jouvert von Arsenal, der Standard-Coach, sogar einen Torbonus bekommt. Wird jetzt von die Athletik enthüllt. Also man sieht, wie groß der Fokus darauf ist. Und ja, wenn man sich das anschaut, es ist nicht immer schön. Der Trend geht dahin, dass der 5-Meter-Raum komplett überladen wird. Wir sehen teilweise 16 Mann im Strafraum. Der heftigste Trend bei der Ausführung ist bei diesen In-Swingers zu erkennen. Also die Ecken, die zum Tor getreten werden und nicht weg. Da sind wir im Vergleich zu 2020. Da waren wir bei 50 Prozent. Jetzt sind wir bei 80 Prozent. Und man sieht so richtig, die Methode ist es, den Torwart zuzustellen, beziehungsweise auch Verteidiger zuzustellen. Also man merkt so richtig, wie man hinsieht, wenige schauen auf den Ball, sondern die meisten schauen auf ihre Gegenspieler, offensiv wie defensiv. Es wird geblockt, es wird isoliert, es wird geschubst, es wird gehalten, es entsteht absolutes Chaos. Und das Problem daran ist A, es sieht nicht so ästhetisch aus, B, man merkt so richtig, dass ein Frust bei den Fans entsteht, weil die schiedsrichterische Entscheidung hier grenzen so ein bisschen an Willkür, weil es gibt mehr Ecken in den Fünfer, es gibt mehr Spieler in der Box, aber es gibt nicht mehr Fouls. Und wenn man sich dann die Ecken ansieht, da kannst du quasi jede Ecke abweifen. Und der Frust der Fans wird so ein bisschen daher, wir reden ja immer über diese Millimeter-Entscheidungen beim Upside. Bei den Ecken dagegen herrscht, wie gesagt, absolute Willkür, Chaos, und da wird nichts abgepfiffen. Da ist so ein bisschen der Frust und natürlich auch von der Ästhetik. Also Slot sagt auch, es macht ihm keinen Spaß, dazu zu sehen, auch wenn er zuletzt auch davon profitierte. Kerik sagt, es geht zu weit. Also ja, es ist so ein bisschen Thema in der Premier League aktuell und natürlich auch Thema, weil der Tabellenführer es einfach auch sehr gut praktiziert.
Aber würdest du dazu stimmen? Würdest du auch sagen, es ist nicht schön, zuzusehen? Weil ich würde sagen, eine Ecke, die Gefahr versprüht und die viel wahrscheinlicher zu einem Tor führt als eine andere Eckballvariante, finde ich jetzt ehrlicherweise nicht so schlimm.
Da gebe ich dir Recht und ich finde es auch ein bisschen kurz gedacht, weil ich persönlich schaue, ich habe immer die Unterhaltung meiner Frau, die sagt, das Spiel ging 0-0 aus, das war ja nix, war ja langweilig. Und dann sage ich, ich lasse mir aber jetzt nicht ein Fußballspiel von, ich sage jetzt mal zwei Minuten definieren, es geht ja auch vielmehr um das ganze Spiel, um den Spielfluss, um das Hin und Her und so weiter. Und die Tore sind ja irgendwo die Höhepunkte, aber irgendwie auch nur noch an die spielerischen und da gebe ich dir nämlich Recht. Und es ist ja auch sehr spannend zu sehen, was bei den Ecken passiert. Klar, manchmal ist es wirklich das reinste Chaos und Geschubse, aber es gibt ja auch sehr, sehr viel spannende Varianten und es gibt auch sehr, sehr gute Schützen. Wenn wir jetzt mal Declan Rice ansehen, der bringt die Bälle da mit einem Zug rein, Beckham-esque, ganz bewusst auf den zweiten Pfosten, dann verlängert einer und es wird eingenickt. Es ist ja auch irgendwo auch eine Kunst für sich, sage ich mal. Nichtsdestotrotz merkt man auch, dass aus dem Spiel heraus einfach ein bisschen weniger passiert in dieser Saison, in der Premier League. Und das ist nicht mehr so schön anzusehen. Es ist für mich nicht nur die Ecken selbst, sondern das, was stattdessen passiert, beziehungsweise auf der anderen Seite der Medaille steht. Und das ist so ein bisschen das Problem.
Und vielleicht eigentlich auch das eigentliche Problem, aber wir hängen uns halt alle an den Ecken auf. Aber das ist jetzt nochmal so ein Gedanke. Jakob, du wolltest auch noch was ergänzen?
Ich glaube, es hat aber viel miteinander zu tun. Also in der Premier League ist es ja jetzt schon länger zu sehen. Und Arsenal ist dann natürlich das Paradebeispiel absolut. Aber ich habe auch das Gefühl, dass sich tatsächlich dieser Fokus auf die Ecken auch ganz direkt auf den Rest des Spiels auswirkt. Denn die Kader sind ja teilweise schon so zusammengestellt, dass man wirklich eigentlich nur für diese Standardsituation optimiert ist. Das ist ja bei Arsenal besonders krass. Die haben ja irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, meistens sechs, sieben Leute, die mindestens 1,85 und wuchtig sind in der Startelf. Und ich bin der festen Überzeugung, dass darunter auch die spielerische Qualität dann in den einzelnen Szenen leidet, weil das dann gerade auf den Außenverteidigerpositionen klar soll. Jemand wie Calafuri ist da vielleicht eine Ausnahme, der auch mit dem Ball gut ist. Aber wenn dann auf den Außenverteidigerposition Hinkapie und Timber spielen, die eigentlich Innenverteidiger sind, im Mittelfeld dann Declan Rice und Zubi Mendy. Und dann hast du wirklich nur drei, vier Spieler, die eigentlich echte Offensivspieler sind auf dem Platz. Und die anderen sind alles nur Leute, die dann darauf gepolt sind, bei den Ecken irgendwie im Strafraum den Gegnern auf den Füßen zu stehen, sie festzuhalten und zu faulen. Und ja, ich mag diese Entwicklung echt nicht besonders. Und ich habe jetzt die Highlights gesehen vom Spiel von Arsene gegen Chelsea am Wochenende, von dem Clip, der von den Sky England hochgeladen hat. Der ist, glaube ich, drei Minuten dreißig lang. Und eine einzige Szene ist eine Szene aus dem Spiel heraus. Der Rest waren, glaube ich, neun oder zehn Ecken. Und ich weiß, ich glaube nicht, dass das der Fußball ist, den viele sehen wollen. Also ich will ihn auf jeden Fall nicht so sehen.
Da gebe ich dir absolut recht. Und ich glaube, das rührt halt auch ein bisschen daher. Man sieht in der Premier League, dass die breite und die schlechteren Teams immer besser werden. Sie werden vor allem defensiv immer besser. Das heißt, die mittleren Blöcke, die tiefen Blöcke sind immer intensiver. Und es geht ja nicht nur bei Arsenal der Trend dahin, sondern von der gesamten Liga sich auf Standards ein bisschen vermerkt zu konzentrieren. Und das liegt halt daran, dass man versucht, sich irgendwie einen Vorteil zu verschaffen. Ich meine, Guardiola und Atetta haben es auch kürzlich gesagt, es ist auch irgendwo eine Evolution. Der Sport verändert sich und man versucht immer, irgendwo einen Vorteil rauszuholen. Und gerade auf Arsenal bezogen, sie spielen momentan keinen schönen Fußball bzw. sehr selten. Ich habe das Gefühl, in der Premier League, jetzt will ich auch nicht zu weit abschweifen, aber es ist auch ein bisschen Kopfsache bei Arsenal. Du bist jetzt dreimal hintereinander Vizemeister geworden, willst unbedingt Meister werden. Da geht es nicht mehr um das Wie, sondern darum, es endlich mal zu schaffen. Und man spürt auch so richtig, dass Arsenal in der Champions League einen anderen Fußball spielt. Viel befreiter, viel offener, viel mehr Spielfluss. Und in der Premier League ist man ein bisschen verkrampft und das ist auch Kopfsache. Das hat auch Jürgen Timber kürzlich gesagt, dass man das in den Griff bekommen muss und man spürt da regelmäßig die Angst auf dem Platz. Und deswegen igelt man sich so ein bisschen ein, weiß, man kann gut verteidigen und irgendeinen Standard jetzt richten. Ist nicht schön, ist nicht schön anzusehen, aber vielleicht mit diesem Kontext ein bisschen eher zu verstehen, warum das passiert.
Christian?
Ja, ich wollte auch nur kurz darauf eingehen, weil das auch definitiv in der Serie A ein Thema ist. Also vielleicht schwappt das dann auch aus der Premier League rüber. In der Serie A, wenn man sich die Ergebnisse zuletzt anschaut, auch gerade bei großen Spielen, die wurden ganz oft sehr spät, in der Nachspielzeit teilweise, erst entschieden. Späte Tore, entscheidende Tore. Und da gibt es jetzt auch immer häufiger, sozusagen das hört man auch immer häufiger von Beobachtern, auch aus dem Umfeld von Teams, gibt es manche auch, die fordern ja vielleicht wirklich so ein Set-Play-Trainer, auch sozusagen so ein bisschen NFL-artig quasi. Wirklich solche Situationen halt, genau eben wirklich noch, also ist ja klar, alle bereiten Standards vor, das ist ja nichts Neues, aber wirklich für so Momente in den letzten Minuten, wenn die Spiele eben eng sind, da vielleicht nochmal was im Köcher zu haben, was ja, was dann so ein großes Spiel auch entscheiden kann. Und wie Chris ja sagt, ich meine, die Spitze ist so eng, da reden wir am Ende, machen zwei oder drei Punkte den Unterschied aus. Also wenn du einmal in der 90. den Standard so ausspielst oder zu Ende gespielt kriegst, wie du ihn dir vorstellst, dann macht das womöglich den Unterschied zu Meister oder Nicht-Meister aus oder Champions League Ja oder Nein. Und das ist wirklich sehr spannend. Einen interessanten Punkt wollte ich noch mit reinbringen, den Gasperini auch immer wieder anführt. Ich würde auch sagen, die 5 Wechsel haben auch ein bisschen was damit zu tun, weil du einfach so viele, du kannst im Prinzip deine halbe, mittlerweile kannst du deine halbe Falschspielermannschaft auswechseln. Das heißt, du kannst wirklich auch in den letzten Minuten, wir hatten gerade das Beispiel in Italien, Roma gegen Juventus im vergangenen Wochenende, da fällt das 3-3 in der Nachspielzeit, da bringt der Espalletti in der 90. Gatti. Und er bringt ihn logischerweise nicht, um hinten nochmal was zu machen, sondern er bringt ihn, um im gegnerischen 16. und nochmal mit dieser physischen Präsenz was auszulösen. Am Ende macht Gatti sogar das Tor, das mag jetzt in dem Fall ein bisschen Zufall gewesen sein, aber auch Gasperini sagt, diese 5 Wechsel haben halt auch die Natur des Spiels irgendwie verändert. Und ich würde sagen, gerade in solchen engen Spielen in den letzten Minuten, wenn du dann 2, sage ich mal, 1,95 Kanten da vorne nochmal reinstellst, dann fliegen da zwei Bälle rein, womöglich eine Ecke oder ein guter Einwurf. Ja, und dann kippt womöglich so ein Spiel. Also in Italien definitiv auch ein Thema.
Es ist spannend, dass du das auch sagst, dass man dann so Spezialisten hat und Setplay-Trainer, weil ich habe jetzt auch gelesen, dass der Einfluss der NFL immer größer auf die Premier League wird. Und man sieht ja auch beispielsweise bei Arsenal die Connection, die Rams, die LA Rams, gehören auch Kronke, dem Besitzer oder dem Mehrteilseigner des FC Arsenal. Und Arteta soll auch oft in Kontakt mit Sean McVey sein, dem Trainer der Rams. Und wenn man sich mal die Standards ansieht, das ist sehr ähnlich zum American Football, weil es geht im Ende darum, Spieler frei zu skieben, sagt man ja in der NFL. Also irgendwie einen Weg zu finden, Spieler X frei zu bekommen. Und das ist genau das, was Arsenal bei Standards macht. Am besten Gabriel frei bekommen, der ist der Kopfballstärkste, der Wuchtigste. Und das ist dann das Ziel der Sache. Und wie gesagt, man sucht sich in jeder Situation irgendwie einen Vorteil gegenüber den anderen Mannschaften zu finden. Und das ist auch ein Trend. Andere Mannschaften erkennen das, wollen das dann auch tun. Das funktioniert in jedem Sport so. Und wie gesagt, auch Arteta meinte kürzlich, es ist immer schwieriger, aus dem Spieler aus Tore zu erzählen in der Premier League. Guardiola sagte das kürzlich. Und dementsprechend versuchen Mannschaften jetzt in diesem Bereich verstärkt, sich Vorteile zu erzielen.
Ich finde aber dennoch, dass es auch, wenn man natürlich sehen kann, dass es dann schöne Varianten gibt und so, es schon auch noch einen Unterschied gibt zwischen dem, was jetzt in der Premier League gerade passiert, dass man wirklich es dann zwar noch so vielleicht Varianten sind, aber es ist dann, also ich weiß nicht, hat Arsene nicht auch schon zwei, drei direkte Eckballtore gemacht, weil der Torwart einfach so zugestellt bzw. behindert wurde, dass er sich noch nicht mal bewegen konnte, um nicht nur eine Flanke abzufangen, sondern tatsächlich einen Ball aufs Tor zu verhindern. Und ich finde, das geht dann auch ein ganzes Stück zu weit. Also ich finde, wenn man, wie ja zum Beispiel England bei der WM 2.18, wo sie immer diesen Love Train hatten, wo sie dann alle hintereinander ausgeschwärmt sind, sowas finde ich dann auch noch mal deutlich netter anzugucken, als wirklich nur 20 Spieler, die im Fünfer stehen. Und dann ist es halt im Grunde einfach nur purer Zufall. Na ja, nicht purer Zufall, aber es ist halt aus meiner Sicht einfach nicht so schön anzugucken. Und vielleicht ein Aspekt, der da sicherlich auch noch eine Rolle spielt, ist ja auch der Videoschiedsrichter, weil man muss ja sagen, dass für die angreifende Mannschaft die Kosten, viel Körpereinsatz mit reinzubringen, sehr, sehr gering sind. Weil im Zweifelsfall kriegen sie halt, kriegt das gegnerische Team Freistoß. Aber die Szene wird ja sowieso vom WRA auch nur überprüft, wenn tatsächlich ein Tor fällt. Und die verteidigende Mannschaft kann sich ja praktisch kaum wehren, weil sobald sie mal einen Trikotsupfer sich leistet, geht sie immer das Riesenrisiko ein, dass es völlig egal, wo der Ball landet, es einen Elfmeter gibt. Und das ist sicherlich auch noch ein Bestandteil, der das schon noch mal ein bisschen aus dem Gleichgewicht gebracht hat, das Verhältnis zwischen Angriffs- und Abwehrmöglichkeiten.
Ja, sehr guter Punkt. Und die Parallele zur NFL geht da sogar noch weiter. Also wer sich mit der NFL beschäftigt, da gibt es ein Play, den Tusch-Pusch, den haben die Philadelphia Eagles reingebracht. Grob gesagt, also für alle, die jetzt nicht NFL verfolgen, da wird mit sehr, sehr vielen Menschen, wird einfach der Quarterback nach vorne geschoben. Und damit holt man dann die entscheidenden letzten Jahres. Und es gab da schon mal Initiativen, dieses Play zu verbieten, weil das viele Teams nicht so gut können, wie manche andere Teams, und die haben einen enormen Vorteil dadurch. Also so ein bisschen die Situation, wie jetzt. Wenn es jemals verboten werden sollte, dann prophezeihe ich, es ist deshalb, weil du in diesem Menschenknoil nicht mehr erkennen kannst, ob irgendwelche Strafen stattfinden. Und weil es tatsächlich auch Fälle gab, wo man im Nachhinein sagen muss, klare Strafen wie in falsche Staaten, verfrühte Staaten und so weiter, wurden nicht gepfiffen. Und das könnte ich mir tatsächlich hier auch vorstellen, sollte es da irgendwie wieder eine Rückentwicklung geben, dann wird es über die Regeln kommen. Weil man eben tatsächlich oft dann gar nicht mehr erkennen kann, war das Freiblocken jetzt noch völlig in Ordnung oder nicht. Und gerade wenn es an die Torhüter geht, die haben ja wirklich manchmal, also die Torhüter werden ja inzwischen fast schon so ein bisschen verfolgt im Strafraum. Egal, wo sie sich hinstellen, sie haben quasi so ein Block aus drei Gegenspielern um sich außen rum. Und das ist natürlich auch, ja, also ich verstehe die Problematik. Ich habe aber den Eindruck, Chris, dass der Frust auch daher kommt, dass es halt insgesamt, das ist nicht nur der Anteil der Tore so hoch ist, sondern dass sich insgesamt das Spiel eben einfach in der Premier League verändert hat. Also ob der Analyst, die Analyst hat da einen wunderbar überschriebenen Titel zu, Artikel zugemacht mit Nill, nilling me softly, weil es eben jetzt schon die Saison mit den meisten 0 zu 0 spielen seit ganz, ganz vielen Jahren ist. Und die zeigen eben sehr gut auf. Die Schüsse sind zurückgegangen, die Ballkontakte im Strafraum nur hochgegangen, weil du die, weil du die Ecken dann tatsächlich mit reinrechtest. Es gibt insgesamt, also seit 2003, 2004 ist das aktuell die Saison mit den zwei wenigsten Schüssen, die wir pro Spiel haben. Und das hängt natürlich alles miteinander zusammen. Du hast ja auch schon angesprochen. Aber ich glaube, daher kommt auch der Frust, wenn wir jetzt immer 4 zu 4 Spiele sehen würden oder 4 zu 3 Spiele. Und dann sind halt jeweils zwei oder drei Tore nach Ecken. Ich glaube, dann würden wir alle uns weniger beschweren dadurch, dass wir halt oft ein 1 zu 0 sehen. Und dadurch, dass wir schon ganz oft gesehen haben, der Glenn Reiss läuft zur Ecke, wird von den heimischen Fans beschimpft, während er die Ecke ausführt. Und danach ist das komplette Stadion ruhig. Also das ist ja schon so ein Meme geworden eigentlich. Ich habe schon drei, vier solcher Videos gesehen. Ich glaube, nur deswegen ist der Frust so groß, oder?
Absolut, absolut. Und das Problem ist auch so ein bisschen, wie soll ich sagen, wenn man sich die Statistiken ansieht. Also zunächst einmal, ich glaube, auch Arsene kriegt die meiste Kritik ab, weil man einfach Tabellenführer ist. Und wenn man Tabellenführer ist, dann ist man so ein bisschen auch so dieses Vorbild der Liga.
Da muss es dir auch verdient haben.
Genau.
Eigentlich eine urdeutsche Debatte, aber schön, dass das auch in der Premier League stattfindet.
Genau. Erstens das und zweitens auch, ist man da oft auch Trendsetter für Spielweisen. Und dann bekommt man einfach die Sorge, okay, die ganze Liga entwickelt sich dahin. Tut sie übrigens auch. Aber irgendwo ist es natürlich auch opportunistisch, weil, wenn man sieht, Arsene begegnet, statistisch gesehen, den tiefsten Blöcken der Premier League. Also die meisten Gegner von Arsenal stellen sich hinten rein. Gegen kein Team stellen sich die Teams so tief hinten rein. Und dass Arsenal offensiv ein bisschen Probleme hat, Jörg Harris beispielsweise, scheint jetzt nicht so wirklich die Wunschlösung zu sein. Da muss man eben Wege finden, irgendwie trotzdem die Tore zu schießen. Und dann kommt natürlich noch der Punkt dazu, den ich gerade sagte. Dann spielt noch die Psyche ein bisschen mit, dann ist man ein bisschen risikoervers, weil man Sorge hat. Und zack, wird daraus ein sehr, sehr unattraktives Produkt. Dass man es dann trotzdem über die Bühne kriegt, ist ein anderes Thema. Aber was man dagegen tun kann, das hast du vorhin gut angesprochen, Arteta selbst sagte kürzlich, dass man wohl die Regeln ändern muss. Und das ist wieder so ein klassisches Beispiel von Don't hate the player, hate the game. Wenn man sich da Wege sucht, damit umzugehen oder sich Vorteile zu verschaffen, dann kann man eigentlich nicht auf die Person oder die Mannschaften sauer sein, sondern muss man den Hut ziehen. Was man ändern kann, sind die Umstände. Und es gab da schon ein paar Vorschläge. Ein Ex-Serie-Assistent, Darren Cannon, sagte beispielsweise– und das finde ich zum Beispiel sehr interessant –,Dass die angreifende Mannschaft oder auch alle außerhalb des Finvers starten müssen. Das wäre schon mal ein Weg, ein Ansatz zumindest. Dann könntest du den Torwart nicht mehr so zustellen, dann ist das alles ein bisschen flüssiger. Man könnte auch darüber reden, dass es Fouls bereits vor der Ausführung des Eckballs gibt. Normalerweise muss die Eckball angepfiffen werden. Erst, wenn der Ball in der Luft ist, beginnt die Situation und dann wird abgepfiffen. Was davor passiert, Bangelein etc., wird nicht unterbunden bzw. nur kurz angesprochen. Das sind alles Methoden, mit denen man das vielleicht ein bisschen mehr in den Griff bekommen könnte.
Mein Kopftreffer-Gehirn, also darauf spezialisiertes Gehirn, mir wird heiß und kalt, wenn ich darüber vorstelle, dass die vom 16 Meter reinlaufen und die anderen warten drin. Dann würde ich eher sagen hohe Ecken verbieten. Aber dann hassen mich jetzt wirklich alle. Deswegen, ich weiß schon, es wird nicht kommen. Jakob, du wolltest noch mal sagen.
Ich habe auch nur einen kurzen Gedanken noch zu dem, was man dagegen tun könnte, fernab von der Regeländerung. Ich habe das in einigen Spielen in den unteren Ligen in England, wenn ich mal reingeguckt habe, gesehen, dass es vereinzelt Teams gab, die drei, vier Spieler an der Mittellinie platziert haben und dann damit versucht haben, den Strafraum wieder ein bisschen freier zu machen. Ich weiß nicht, ob das langfristig funktioniert. Ich fand es aber zumindest einen interessanten Gedanken und habe gedacht, dass man fernab von dem hoffen, dass sich die Leute beim IFAB irgendwas Gutes überlegen, dass man vielleicht auch eine taktische Evolution findet, um dem Ganzen vorzubeugen, weil damit würde man zumindest das angreifende Team zwingen. Entweder wir nehmen welche zurück oder wir sind uns so sicher, dass wir den Ball reinkriegen, dass wir trotzdem das Risiko eingehen, hinten so offen zu stehen.
Chelsea hat das schon ein paarmal probiert, also gegen Arsenal ist mir das aufgefallen. Da hat man es schon probiert und Arsenal hat dann auch ein paar Spieler zurückgezogen, um den Konter quasi abzusichern. Aber wie du sagst, es gibt, es wird Möglichkeiten geben und es werden sich Möglichkeiten auch auftun, wie Mannschaften versuchen, dem Ganzen zu entgegnen. Aber ich glaube trotzdem, dass man gerade auf den 5-Meter-Raum vielleicht ein bisschen mehr Fokus legen muss, weil gerade in England bekommt der Keeper wirklich da nicht viel Unterstützung von den Schiedsrichtern. Und das ist, da muss ich Jakob auch zustimmen, das ist für mich auch nicht mehr im Sinne des Sports, dass der Torhüter da rausgeblockt wird, zur Seite geschoben wird und dann gar nicht mehr an den Ball kommt. Also ich bin auch der Meinung, dass sich da vielleicht was tun muss.
Gibt es vielleicht den besonderen Schutz innerhalb des 5-Meter-Raums dann doch wieder? Die ganz Älteren werden sich noch erinnern. Ja, wir hatten ja auch schon ein Bundesligaspiel, wo man auch schon in diese Richtung debattieren konnte. Borussia Dortmund gegen den 1. FSV Mainz 05. Die 4-Vorlagenshow von Julian Riazón, wo eben auch Batz im Mainzer Tor eben zwar auch nicht gut aussah, aber eben auch genau mit solchen Problemen zu kämpfen hatte. Also, dass er eben einfach zugestellt wurde und ein etwas vielleicht erfahrener Torhüter oder jemand, der mehr Wettkampfpraxis aktuell hat, der wäre da vielleicht ein bisschen rustikaler einfach bei dem gewesen, wie er sich befreit hätte. Also, ihr könnt auch mal drauf schauen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, was z.B. Manuel Neuer macht, wenn der so zugestellt wird. Zwischendurch sieht er aus wie ein Feldspieler und erst nur an seinem Trikot und seinen Handschuhen siehst du, dass er eigentlich ein Torhüter ist. Also, der rempelt, der schubs, der passt, der packt mal so um die Hüfte, dreht einfach so die Hüfte weg, schiebt sich vorbei und so weiter. Alles bevor der Ball im Spiel ist. Also, das wird sich sicherlich wahrscheinlich auch noch so ein bisschen anpassen, wie die Torhüter das spielen. Jakob, du wirst dieses Thema, es hört nicht auf, es elektriziert uns, oder?
Ja, das hat nur gerade einen Gedanken geweckt, denn es gab ja auch schon mal den Trend, dass man zwischenzeitlich mal kleinere, vielleicht schnellere Innenverteidiger hatte. Jetzt sind sie ja in den letzten Jahren wieder deutlich größer geworden. Vielleicht wird es ja auch so, dass es einfach in ein paar Jahren dann wirklich nur noch 2 Meter Hüner als Torhüter gibt, wenn tatsächlich kein anderer Weg gefunden wird, die dann so wie Manuel Neuersich halt den entsprechenden Platz dann auch wirklich körperlich einfach verschaffen können.
Wobei man sagen muss, dass David Reijer jetzt auch zu den kleineren Keepern gehört. Und ich finde das irre, was der für eine Strafraumbeherrschung hat. Also klar, in der Regel wird sich da ein größerer, stärkerer Torhüter öfter durchsetzen. Aber es ist nicht nur das. Also es ist schon beachtlich.
Letzter Satz vielleicht noch, um das Thema abzuschließen. In Italien gab es wirklich vor kurzem auch. Milan verliert durch so eine Situation 0-1 gegen Parma, weil Menyam von zwei Parma-Spielern so gut geblockt wird, dass es nicht ein Foul war. Und dann fällt das Tor. Die Klammer zu schließen, wer ist Trainer von Parma? Questa, Exquo-Trainer von Arteta. Also, ja, man weiß wahrscheinlich. Nee, es ist wirklich so.
Hat er eine SideQuesta in Italien gestartet.
Ja, wir, glaube ich, wissen alle. Deswegen hat Chris das Thema ja auch aufgemacht. Woher das kommt oder woran sich dann viele Mannschaften auch international halt dran orientieren.
Also, seid nicht überrascht, sollte Arsenal auch in der Champions League damit Erfolg haben. Sie haben sie unter anderem auch schon gegen den FC Bayern gezeigt, wo vorher viel über Standards gesprochen wurde. Aber da hat sich gezeigt, es ist eben dann doch nicht so einfach zu verteidigen. Es hat seinen Grund, warum der Anteil der Standardtore so hoch ist bei Arsenal. Wunderschönes Thema, Chris, du hast es gemerkt. Dann könnten wir die ganze Sendung mit bestreiten. Wir blicken aber trotzdem nochmal nach Frankreich. Denn da gibt es unter anderem ein Team, das sich gerade Hoffnung auf die Champions League machen kann, womit man vielleicht nicht unbedingt rechnen musste, Jakob.
Nee, denn es geht ums da drinnen. Wir hatten über die schon irgendwann im Herbst, glaube ich, mal gesprochen damals, David, der das Thema hatte. Und da waren sie ja, glaube ich, gerade auch im Aufwind eigentlich. Und man muss auch ehrlich sagen, so einen richtig sportlichen Niedergang gab es zwischendurch, auch jetzt zumindest für Start-Rennen-Verhältnisse gar nicht so krass. Dennoch haben sie einen Wechsel auf der Trainerposition vorgenommen. Javi Bey hatten wir in der letzten Sendung auch schon drüber gesprochen, ist jetzt inzwischen in Marseille, wurde bei Rennes entlassen, war dann nur ganz kurz ohne Job. Und Start-Rennen hat mit Franck Aes einen neuen Trainer an der Seitenlinie. Der hat jetzt in den ersten beiden Spielen auch gleich zwei Siege geholt und ist ja generell in Frankreich durchaus einer der geschätztesten Trainer, würde ich sagen, der sicherlich jetzt außerhalb Frankreichs noch nicht so eine große Bekanntheit hat, eben weil er auch bisher nur in Frankreich gecoacht hat und jetzt auch keine riesige Spielerkarriere im Rücken hat. Aber er hat mit Lens unter anderem 22, 23, zum Beispiel eine riesen Überraschung geschafft, ist damit 84 Punkten auf Platz 2 gelandet, also eine ganz fantastische Saison gespielt, ist ansonsten auch dreimal Siebter geworden bei Lens und ist da weiterhin sehr geschätzt, auch wenn es da ja gerade auch gut läuft, auch mit anderen Trainern. Ja, Franck S hat auf jeden Fall auch bis ja in dieser Saison auch entlassen worden in der Ligue 1 bei Nizza. Allerdings da auch so ein bisschen, finde ich, eher Opfer der Umstände geworden. Das hatten wir auch schon mal angesprochen, dass da vieles nicht gut läuft und seine Reputation hat, sieht man jetzt auch an dem neuen Job bei Startrennen dadurch auch kaum Schaden genommen und das meiner Meinung nach auch ziemlich zurecht. Das Schöne dabei ist, dass Franck S auch in der Jugend schon bei Rennes trainiert hat. Also hat von 2.6 bis 2.12 auch die U19 von Rennes trainiert. Also da dann auch schon viel Arbeit im Verein geleistet. Und jetzt, seitdem er da ist, läuft es gut, aber es lief eigentlich auch vorher schon ganz gut. Und so steht man jetzt tatsächlich in der Tabelle momentan auf Platz 6 mit 40 Punkten, hat nur drei Punkte Rückstand auch auf Olympique Marseille auf Platz 4, der ja zumindest für die Champions League-Quali reichen müsste und so auch nur fünf Punkte hinter Platz 3. Also selbst ein Sprung aufs Podium wäre noch drin, zumal die Teams, oben ja jetzt auch alle gerade nicht so konstant punkten bis auf PSG und Lens, jeder so ein bisschen seine eigenen Probleme hat. Und das ist schon durchaus bemerkenswert, denn Startren hatte ja auch gerade zu Saisonbeginn, weswegen ja Abi Bey erst in der Kredik stand, dann sich ja so ein bisschen befreit hat und dann unter anderem nach dem Aus in der Coupe de France ja doch entlassen wurde. Da hatten sie ja eine schwierige Phase und standen dann eher unten drin. Da muss man allerdings auch dazu sagen, damals haben sie nach Expected Points auch ziemlich unterperformt eine Zeit lang. Der Trend hat sich jetzt so ein bisschen verändert. Sie haben jetzt bessere Ergebnisse, dafür performen sie jetzt deutlich über, haben fast 10 Punkte mehr geholt, als es erwartbar gewesen wäre, wenn man sich ein paar Expected-Point-Tabellen anschaut. Also da ist vielleicht so ein bisschen das Fragezeichen dahinter. Allerdings muss man da natürlich jetzt auch gerade mit einem neuen Trainer erstmal abwarten, wie sich das überhaupt entwickeln wird jetzt in Zukunft. Und ich bin sehr gespannt, weil eigentlich ist der Kader von Startrennen nämlich finde ich auch ganz interessant. Sie haben eigentlich eine ganz schöne Mischung aus jungen, talentierten Spielern, aber auch ein paar erfahreneren Spielern und so ein paar, ja vielleicht etwas unbeschriebeneren Blättern, gerade außerhalb Frankreichseinnahme, der da auf jeden Fall zu nennen ist. Das erste Bahn Le Paul im Sturm. Das ist ein jetzt schon 25-jähriger Stürmer, also nicht mehr im klassischen Talentalter. Allerdings ist es erst seine zweite Saison in der Ligue 1. Der war letzte Saison noch bei Angers, hat da neun Tore geschossen, glaube ich, in der Liga und ist dann für 13,5 Millionen im Sommer zu Startrennen gewechselt, auch erst kurz vor Transferschluss. Ist jetzt einer der besten Torschützen in der Liga, hat einen richtig starken, hat den höchsten Non-Penalty-Expected-Goals-Wert. Also er steht, er ist einfach super gut darin, sich in die richtigen Positionen zu bringen, um Tore zu erzielen. Ist so ein bisschen, ja, man kann es klassischer Stürmer nennen, und zwar eigentlich der sozusagen die hängende Spitze im klassischen 4-4-2. Also ein relativ kleiner Stürmer, der jetzt nicht unbedingt eine riesen körperliche Präsenz hat, aber einfach einen guten Antritt hat, sehr clever ist in den Bewegungen und jetzt keine Abwehr durch seine Physis oder so, sonderlich unter Druck setzt, aber halt ein sehr intelligenter Spieler und der auch einen ganz interessanten Weg genommen hat. Denn er ist in der Lyon-Jugend ausgebildet worden, hat dann aber den Umweg über die unteren Ligen genommen, hat bei Epinalje gespielt, bei Orléans und ist dann als Angé noch zweitligest war zu Angé gewechselt, dann mit ihnen aufgestiegen und ist halt jetzt ja im oberen Drittel der Ligue 1 zumindest angekommen und zählt jetzt absolut zu einem der besten Stürmer in Frankreich, also zumindest von den Spielern, die noch in Frankreich spielen. Ansonsten ist die Konkurrenz da ja relativ groß, muss man nochmal ergänzen. Und das ist auf jeden Fall schön zu sehen. Und dann haben sie so ein paar Routiniers, gerade bei denen war ja immer das Thema, dass sie mit Abi Bay auch Probleme gehabt haben sollen, wie man das vernommen hat. Also zum Beispiel hatte Bay kurz vor seiner Entlassung Brice Samba den Torwart aussortiert, beziehungsweise auf die Bank gesetzt. Der ist jetzt wieder im Kasten, ist eigentlich auch nur eine logische Wahl, denn das ist weiterhin einer der besten französischen Keeper. Also es hätte mich jetzt auch überrascht, wenn der langfristig aussortiert worden wäre. Mit Ludovic Blas, ein Spielmacher, der seit Jahren eigentlich in der Liga auch ganz gut performt. Dann haben sie Valentin Rongier, der vor der Saison aus Marseille gekommen ist, auch ein super solider und verlässlicher zentraler Mittelfeldspieler, ist auch Kapitän des Teams. Und dann haben sie halt ein paar Talente, Jérémie Jacquet, über den hatten wir schon mal kurz gesprochen, als wir über die Transfers gesprochen haben, der im Sommer für sehr, sehr viel Geld zu Liverpool wechseln wird, bzw. ja schon gewechselt ist eigentlich. Der fällt jetzt allerdings wahrscheinlich sogar bis Saisonende verletzt aus. Auch so ein bisschen vielleicht als Reaktion darauf hat Franck erst jetzt auch erstmal auf Viererkette umgestellt, was für ihn gar nicht unbedingt üblich ist, denn er hat gerade bei Lens viel Dreierkette auch gespielt. Es ist also auch ganz interessant, dass er da taktisch durchaus flexibel zu sein scheint und dann noch ein Name, der auf jeden Fall erwähnt werden muss, ist Arnaud Nordin, der ja jetzt per Laie im Winter aus Mainz zurück nach Frankreich gekommen ist. Der hat halt bisher auch sehr gut eingeschlagen, hat jetzt schon zwei Scorer gesammelt. In, ich meine, vier Einsätze müsste es gewesen sein, ist da jetzt also absoluter Stammspieler auf den beiden Flügelpositionen.
Und Bréel Emboulon natürlich noch, muss zumindest mal kurz erwähnt werden. Ich will jetzt nicht schon zu positiv über ihn sprechen, weil man dachte das ja schon mehrfach, dass er jetzt dann irgendwann mal das einlöst, was man sich von ihm versprochen hat. Aber schlecht läuft es jetzt auch nicht für ihn, würde ich sagen.
Nee, das stimmt. Obwohl er jetzt auch in den vergangenen Spielen dann häufiger mal von der Bank gekommen ist, aber da auch auf jeden Fall seinen Impact hat. Also ich finde auch, dass der eine echt solide Saison spielt und der ja auch im Sommer erst gewechselt. Also war ja vorher lange bei Monaco. Und ich glaube auch, dass er da gut ist. Und wenn wir schon bei den ehemaligen Bundesligaspielern sind, dann können wir auch noch erwähnen, dass Antonio Ruo in der Innenverteidigung auch Stammspieler ist. Der war ja bei Stuttgart auch mal.
Ja, stimmt. Und Fabian Rieder ist ja auch hingewechselt, aber der spielt kaum, habe ich gesehen. Aber ja gut, aber das ist ja der Circle of Life.
Nee, der ist doch aber schon wieder weg. Ist der nicht in Augsburg jetzt?
Stimmt, ja klar, der ist in Augsburg. Da spielt er nämlich auch. Richtig lustig. Ja, heute ist ein bisschen was anderes an meinem Setup. Da bin ich nicht so flink beim Nachschauen. Ja, aber das ist ja der normale Circle of Life, dass quasi die französischen Fußballtalente, sie werden in die Welt geboren, sie werden in ein Weidenkörbchen gesetzt von einem Ligue 1-Verein und landen in der Bundesliga. Und irgendwann, wenn die Bundesliga sagt, die sind vermeintlich zu schlecht für uns, eigentlich, wenn man sich nur neue Weidenkörbchen liefern lassen, dann schickt man sie halt wieder zurück. Deswegen irgendwann ist es immer so, dass wir hier ganz viele Bundesliga-Bezüge haben bei Ligue 1-Vereinen. Die Armen kriegen immer dann die ausgewachsenen Kinder zurück. Na gut, ich treibe diese Analogie nicht weiter. Aber ganz kurz, wenn man es in einem Satz beantworten kann, ist das Titelrennen jetzt doch durch? 4 Punkte ist PSG vor und L'Anse hat jetzt neulich unentschieden gespielt oder verloren sogar. Ich habe es nur so am Rande mitbekommen. Ach ja, okay, ja stimmt. Daher kommen dann nämlich auch 4 Punkte zustande, Max. Meine Güte, heute ist irgendwie nicht mein Tag. Also ist das durch? Ist der Drops gelutscht, der berühmte?
Ja, es ist noch nicht gelutscht. PSG tut sich auch schwer, aber es ist natürlich zu befürchten, dass L'Anse das Tempo nicht aufrechterhalten kann. Sie hatten jetzt auch zwei schwere Spiele mit dem Spiel gegen Monaco, was sie verloren haben, dann nur unentschieden bei Straßburg gespielt. Aber ja, ich glaube nicht, dass sie es schaffen werden. Und am Ende wird PSG sich höchstwahrscheinlich die Meisterschaft holen.
Na ja, es waren schöne paar Wochen, als wir dachten, es könnte anders werden. Man kennt es ja schon.
Sie spielen aber auch noch gegeneinander, also theoretisch.
Stimmt, stimmt, das kommt ja noch richtig. Also in der Theorie ist es noch möglich. Und aber bei Verfolgenden, also Platz 1 gegen Platz 2, die gegeneinander spielen und vielleicht nur noch in der Theorie möglichen Meisterschaften, da sind wir dann auch wieder in der Serie A gelandet. Christian, was ist da los? All die Jahre, die letzten Jahre Ligatour, hieß es immer das spannendste Meisterschaftsrennen in ganz Europa. Es waren vier, fünf, wenn man so wollte, manchmal sogar sechs Teams, die man da mit reinrechnen konnte. Und jetzt gucke ich auf die Serie A-Tabelle zugegebenermaßen zum ersten Mal wieder seit der letzten Ligatour und sehe zehn Punkte sind es zwischen Inter und Milan. Wie konnte das passieren?
Ja, die schöne Spannung, die wir noch vor ein paar Wochen hatten, die ist dahin. Also fangen wir mal so an. Am Wochenende steht das Derby an in Mailand. Inter, wie du schon gesagt hast, zehn Punkte Vorsprung. Es ist insofern schade, dass Milan gerade in der jüngeren Vergangenheit, vergangenen Woche, gleich fünf Punkte liegen hat lassen. Die hatten Nachholspiel gegen Kormor. Das spielen sie daheim eins zu eins. Das ist logisch völlig okay, weil Kormor ja auch da vorne mit dabei ist. Gar kein Thema. Bitter war dann eben wenige Tage später diese gerade eben angesprochene Heim-Niederlage gegen Parma, weil da hast du dann drei Punkte verloren, die du schon hättest haben können. Und ich sag mal so, die du auch aus dem Spiel heraus, muss man sagen, vor diesem 0-1-Spät, Leao trifft die Latte, da war schon vieles dabei bei Milan, dass sie das Spiel auch hätten knapp gewinnen können. Und ich sag mal so, wenn du mit sieben Punkten Rückstand in das Derby reingehst, das ist ein Heimspiel für Milan, du solltest es gewinnen, vier Punkte, würde ich sagen, schaut dann schon anders aus. Jetzt aber ist es wirklich so, ich glaube, selbst wenn Milan es gewinnt, dann wären es eben sieben Punkte, ist Inter im Moment einfach zu stabil. Und deswegen wollte ich auch schon kurz auf Inter drauf eingehen. So sehr enttäuschend dieses Aus gegen Bodo Glimt war, da müssen wir nicht drum herum reden. Das war logischerweise, ich glaube, das haben sich die wenigsten erwartet, dass das Inter da so rausgeht, auch beide Spiele verliert. Also wirklich eine riesen, riesen, riesen Enttäuschung, gar keine Frage. Aber was sie in der Liga seit Monaten spielen, ist fast schon außerirdisch. Ich nenne nur eine Zahl von den letzten 15 Liga-Spielen, hat Inter 14 gewonnen und einmal unentschieden gegen Napoli gespielt. Also, den Rhythmus, den Inter einfach anschlägt, der ist zu gut für den Rest in dieser Saison. Also, die 10 Punkte Rückstand haben weniger damit zu tun, dass Milan zu schlecht ist und dass Inter zu gut ist. Milan hat zum Beispiel im Moment auch gleich viel Punkte, wie letztes Jahr zu diesem Zeitpunkt dort der Ballen führende neben Napoli. Milan hat gleich viele Punkte, wie sie unter Piolli hatten vor vier Jahren, als sie Meister wurden zu diesem Zeitpunkt. Also, Milan macht eigentlich aus seinen Mitteln, würde ich mal sagen, Milan kann man nicht groß was vorwerfen, aber was Inter eben in der Liga macht, ist zu souverän. In diesem Jahr, wie gesagt, 14 aus 15, glaube ich, kann man einfach so stehen lassen. Und dementsprechend ist es jetzt schade, dass Milan zuletzt jetzt ein paar Punkte verloren hat. Da hätte es noch enger sein können, aber man muss bei all der riesen Enttäuschung, die Inter da jetzt in der Champions League fabriziert hat, aus italienischer Sicht, muss man einfach festhalten in der Liga, sie gewinnen alles, was sie gewinnen müssen. Ich glaube, gegen die auf der rechten Tabellenseite, du brauchst das Spiel gar nicht anpfeifen, Inter gewinnt die Spiele alle. Und gegen die Großen haben sie jetzt zuletzt auch, haben sie gegen Juventus das erste Mal gewonnen. Klar, das hat man, das war schon besonders geschmäcklich, logisch mit dieser gelben-roten Karte gegen Kalulu. Aber sie sind einfach zu stabil im Moment.
Und, also ich will jetzt nicht Wasser in den Wein gießen, aber ich würde das gerne verstehen. Wie ordnest du denn das Ausscheiden gegen Bodo ein? Wo man ja sogar im Rückspiel zwar natürlich besser gespielt hat, aber ja noch mal verloren. Also das ist ja, glaube ich, das, was so weh tut. Man kann mal in Norwegen, weil das ist schon genügend passiert, dass es nicht so lief. Aber das Rückspiel hat richtig wehgetan.
Definitiv. Also ich fange mal so an, das ist jetzt logisch eine Vermutung von mir. Die werden wir jetzt nicht belegt bekommen und schon gar nicht von Inter-Seite. Aber ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass bei Inter intern, nach der Erfahrung des letzten Saisons, wo es ja bis zum Schluss gerade überall im Spiel war, um dann am Ende mit leeren Händen dazustehen, dass sie sich intern vielleicht ein bisschen unterbewusst für die Liga entschieden haben. Dafür muss man sich nur die Aufstellung im Hinspiel bei Böödo anschauen. Federico Di Marco ist im Moment nicht nur MVP in Italien, ich würde sagen, der ist im Moment auch MVP-Kandidat in ganz Europa. Also was der seit Wochen spielt, ist völlig über der Norm. Der steht jetzt als Wingback bei 22 Scorer-Punkten in der Liga, 6 Tore, 15 Vorlagen. Also das ist wirklich über allem vorstellbar. Und der saß in Bodo 90 Minuten auf der Bank und er war nicht verletzt. Denn drei Tage später hat er in Lecce gespielt, wo er übrigens auch die zwei Tore vorbereitet hat. Also was ich damit sagen will, vielleicht hat Inter aus der vergangenen Saison, es ist ja auch das erste Jahr unter Kiwu, es ist ein Trainer, der nur 13 Spiele Profi-Erfahrung hatte. Und vielleicht haben sie sich ein bisschen unterbewusst gesagt, okay, die Chance dieses Jahr den Scudetto zu holen ist einfach sehr groß. Und mit der Vorgeschichte, dass wir letztes Jahr bis zum Schluss überall alles probiert haben, aber am Ende eben mit leeren Händen dastanden, ist für mich, also für mich schimmert es so ein bisschen durch. Es war nicht nur die Di Marco, der am Hinspiel, Toram kam von der Bank, Cielinski war auf der Bank, kam auch erst rein, der spielt seit Wochen überragend, Bisseck war auf der Bank, der eigentlich auch Stamm ist. Also ich will damit nicht sagen, dass sie sie unterschätzt haben, aber der Fokus lag vielleicht da schon etwas mehr auf der Liga und dann ist das eingetreten, was du völlig richtig sagst. Ich finde auch, du kannst auswärts auf dem Kunstrassen im Hoden Norden verlieren und dann hast du halt im Rückspiel, du schießt dieses Tor nicht, dieses 1-0-Feld nicht. Wenn das gefallen wäre, glaube ich, dann hätte Bodo schon auch noch ein paar Fragezeichen bekommen, da hätten vielleicht auch 10 Minuten am Ende noch gereicht, um das zweite nachzulegen. Aber klar, du schießt das Tor nicht, Bodo hat es wirklich gut gemacht. Und dann fällt, ich fand das Gefühl, nach dem 0-1 von Bodo war das Ding eigentlich durch, auch wenn da noch Zeit war. Und deswegen ist das logisch schon, bin ich da auch voll dabei. Ich bin immer ein Freund davon in der Champions League, nur anhand der Runde, wo man ausscheidet. Das ist für mich nicht nur das einzige Wertungssignal. Denn was sagen wir da zu Liverpool letztes Jahr, die zwar im Achtelfinale rausgehen, aber halt die gegen PSG rausgehen. Also das ist halt die Champions League, dass du manchmal auch schon in frühen Runden große Spiele hast, aber aus Intersicht in den Playoffs mit der Vorgeschichte der letzten Jahre, der positiven gegen Bodo, mit zwei Niederlagen rausgehen, ist logischerweise schon sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr bitter. Gar keine Frage.
Aber Liga sieht es gut aus. Coppa Italia hatten wir noch das Rückspiel gegen Como. Hinspiel war 0 zu 0. Como auch. Also unglaublich, Cezs Fabrikas. Heiß ist das Trainer Eisen seit ganz, ganz langer Zeit, glaube ich, auf dem Trainermarkt.
Da reden wir nochmal in Ruhe drüber. Ich werfe nur eine Zahl rein. Dieses, ihr kennt es sicher alle, oder? Das europäische, wie heißt das Board? CES, dieses Fußball-Board, das ja immer wieder so Statistiken und so herausgibt. Die haben gerade vergangene Woche eine Pressing-Statistik herausgegeben. Die haben sich alle 96 Mannschaften der Top-5-Ligen Europas, haben sie ein Ranking erstellt nach verschiedenen Pressing-Signalen. Spoiler, Milan ist auf Platz 96 von 96 Mannschaften. Und auf Platz 1 steht Como in dieser Dinge. Die Bayern auf 3, logisch die ganzen großen da vorne mit drin. Barca auch hoch drin, PSG hoch drin. Aber an 1 steht Como, also nur mal kurz hingeworfen. Also ja, da gibt es interessante Aspekte.
Und ich stelle diese Frage nicht so oft, aber wo kann man denn dieses Derby Milano sehen und wer ist denn da vielleicht am Mikro?
Ja, Sonntagabend, 20.45 Uhr, schöne San Siro-Zeit. Und Mario und ich haben die große Ehre, sogar in San Siro vor Ort zu sein. Also wir begleiten das Ganze aus San Siro. Ja, das wird logisch, ist große Vorfreude da. Wir basteln jetzt schon die ganzen Tage dran an einem schönen Paket. Wir gehen schon eine halbe Stunde davor, geht das Sonnen quasi auf Sendung. Ich kann auch schon verraten, da gibt es im Vorfeld auch ein paar nette Aspekte, die da gelungen wurden, aufzuziehen und ja, deswegen ist die Freude diesmal vielleicht noch ein bisschen größer, weil man in diesem Fußball-Tempel dann auch das Ganze vor Ort begleiten darf.
Ich kann dir sagen, nicht nur bei dir ist die Freude groß. Ich habe gestern Abend Mario auch noch getroffen und der hat auch schon wilde Hopping-Pläne. Ich weiß nicht, ob du das weißt, aber wenn ihr eure Aufsager schnell genug in den Kasten bekommt, dann schafft er noch Udiné gegen, ist es nicht sogar Komo?
Atalanta. Gegen Atalanta, genau.
Die Zugverbindung hat er schon rausgesucht. Das ist einfach ganz fantastisch. Meine Neid ist tatsächlich in dem Fall grenzenlos. Ich wünsche euch ganz viel Spaß dabei.
Ich werde euch berichten. Danke.
Leistet euch nicht zu viele Disziplinlosigkeiten, möchte ich sagen. Ihr müsst fit sein. Und damit habe ich mir etwas, ja, etwas kantig eine Überleitung gebaut. Denn Disziplinlosigkeiten, die sind das Problem von Chelsea, Chris. Und das ist ja immer so ein Thema, weil manchmal sagt das was aus und manchmal ist es einfach nur Pech. Wie ist es denn bei Chelsea? Sag uns erst mal, wie ist denn die Lage da gerade?
Ja, also vor gestern Abend, als man ja ich will mal sagen von von Aston Villas jährlicher XG-Regression profitierte und wieder ein Sieg einfahren konnte, gab es zuletzt drei Spiele in Folge ohne Sieg. Man verspielte ein 2-0 gegen Leeds, ein 1-0 gegen Burnley und dann verlor man noch gegen Arsenal 2-1. Und ja, ein großer Grund, warum diese Spiele nicht gewonnen wurden. Liam Rosenoir sagte, wir verlieren Punkte nicht wegen unseren Leistungen. Und was er damit meinte, ist die von dir angesprochene Disziplin. Hauptgrund sind Platzverweise und Karten. Und in zwei dieser drei Spiele gab es einen Platzverweis jeweils. Und insgesamt hat Chelsea in dieser Saison schon sieben Platzverweise. Elberton ist auf Platz zwei mit vier. Das heißt, ein Platzverweis alle vier Spiele etwa. Und noch neun Spiele, um den Premier League-Rekord einzustellen. Der liegt bei neun. Und das ist nicht nur ein Premier League-Problem. In allen Wettbewerben hat Chelsea neun Platzverweise. Und die gehen an neun verschiedene Spieler. Von daher sieht man, es ist ein, ja, es ist schon ein größeres Problem. Und vor allem, wenn man in der Premier League schaut, da gab es, wie gesagt, diese sieben. Und es gab nur einen Platzverweis, als Chelsea hinten lag. Und trotzdem ging nur ein Spiel von diesen sieben Spielen gewonnen. Ich bin jetzt für euch. Es ist ein bisschen schwierig, sich das zu entrösen, aber man sieht, man schneidet sich da einfach selbst ins eigene Fleisch. Und es ist ein Trend, denn letztes Jahr war man Letzter in der Play-Tabelle, das Jahr davor Vorletzter, das Jahr davor Letzter. Und besonders krass fand ich die Statistik, ob da wertet gelbe Karten auch nach Disziplinlosigkeiten, heißt Ball wegschlagen, Schiedsrichter anmeckern etc. Und seit der Saison 2023-2024 hat Chelsea 125 gelbe Karten für Disziplinlosigkeiten bekommen, also nicht für normale Fouls. Und das ist fast 50 mehr als jedes andere Team.
Boah, ja okay. Das sind beeindruckende Statistiken. Oberflächliche Analyse meinerseits. Chelsea hat den jüngsten Kader der Premier League, Durchschnittsalter 23 Jahre, sind die einfach alle noch zu grün unter den Ohren und sehen deshalb rot.
Es ist sicherlich ein Grund, aber es ist ziemlich auffällig, dass von sieben dieser neun roten Karten gegen einen Spieler, die über 24 sind. Das sind also nicht nur diese Erfahrungswerte. Es zieht sich einfach auch wie ein rotes Tuch durch die letzten Jahre. Da muss auch einfach was von den Trainern passieren. Mareska beschwerte sich darüber, jetzt Rosé Noir beschwerte sich darüber. Und wenn man sich diese gelben Karten und Platzverweise anschaut, es ist absolut unnötig. Und es ist nicht nur Erfahrung, es ist einfach teilweise dumm. Es sind Konzentrationsaussetzer. Und das spiegelt sich aber auch in einem weiteren Thema, unserem Thema der Woche, würde ich mal behaupten, Standards, nämlich wieder. Denn auch da beweist Chelsea Disziplinlosigkeiten. In den letzten, in den 13 Spielen unter Rosé Noir gab es sieben Tore, sieben Gegentore nach Standardsituation. Das ist ziemlich viel. Und dann schaut man sich diese Tore mal an und man sieht, wie oft Chelsea-Spieler einfach einen Mann übersehen, ihn vergessen, ihn stehen lassen. Und man merkt einfach, dass diese gesamte Chelsea-Mannschaft irgendwo ein Problem mit dem Fokus hat, mit der Konzentration hat. Und das spiegelt sich in den Standards wieder, das spiegelt sich in den roten Karten wieder. Und das ist eben das, was Rosé Noir auch meinte, dass man nicht wegen den Leistungen verliert. Denn Chelsea ist definitiv leistungstechnisch auf dem richtigen Weg unter ihm.
Aber wo würdest du denn jetzt dann von außen betrachtet da ansetzen? Beziehungsweise Jakob hat offenbar eine Idee. Jakob, kannst du lösen?
Ja, ich habe mir nur noch mal kurz den Kader von Chelsea angeguckt. Und es ist halt schon, glaube ich, oder es sieht für mich aus wie ein hausgemachtes Problem. Denn ich glaube, das, was Max angesprochen hat, ist irgendwie schon ein Problem. Vielleicht nicht unbedingt, dass nur die jungen Spieler vom Platz fliegen. Aber es gibt ja eigentlich keinen Führungsspieler im Kader. Also die ältesten Spieler sind, glaube ich, Tosi, aber Biojo und Robert Sanchez, die beide 28 sind. Und jetzt beide für mich auch nicht so nach, okay, wir führen jetzt die Mannschaft an, schreien.
Genau. Du bringst dich schon auf den Punkt, dass genau das wollte ich nämlich sagen. Es ist nicht mal das Problem, dass der gesamte Kader jung ist. Es fehlt wirklich an Führungsspielern. Und das hat auch Robert Hood kürzlich gesagt, das merkt man besonders bei den Standards. Es fehlt dieser Führungsspieler, dieser ruhige Leader, ein John Terry, ein Lampert ist ja auch Wurst. Wer aber jemand, der ein bisschen kühlen Kopf bewahrt, die Spieler ein bisschen dirigiert. Und man merkt einfach, dass zu viele Spieler zu jung, zu hektisch reagieren in gewissen Situationen. Und das ist ein hausgemachtes Problem, weil man eben auch diese Philosophie verfolgt. So viele junge Talente wie möglich zu verpflichten und mit Gewinn weiter zu verkaufen. Aber das direkte Resultat daraus ist einfach eine hohe Fluktuation. Und das führt eben auch dazu, dass du keine klare Hackordnung in diesem Kader hast. Und sowas muss ich ja auch einfach etablieren Jahr für Jahr. Und das hat Chelsea nicht. Und das sind ebenso, glaube ich, diese Nebeneffekte, die man bei Chelsea nicht wirklich auf dem Schirm hatte. Und den Preis zahlt man eben jetzt.
Christian? Ja, ich finde das total spannend, weil wir haben ja Chelsea auch schon oft thematisiert in den letzten Jahren hier. Wir wissen ja alle, wie viel Geld Chelsea in die Hand genommen hat. Was da auch immer auch die Breite im Kader hat man ja auch schon oft genug, dass da ja oft schon schwierig genug ist, quasi auf der Bank zu sitzen bei so viel individueller Qualität, die da immer auch wieder extern dazu geholt wird. Und dann finde ich es schon spannend. Klar, wir erkennen den Ansatz, gerade durch euch, durch eure tollen Hintergrundgeschichten aus der Premier League, was die Idee dahinter ist. Aber ich finde es schon spannend, dass es dann eben nicht auf dem Zettel zu haben oder zumindest nicht gewollt vielleicht auch nicht umzusetzen, dann doch die eine oder zweite Figur da halt doch mit reinzugeben, die vielleicht jetzt, wie du sagst Chris, vielleicht wird da schon einer helfen, der da ein bisschen Ordnung gibt, der einfach eine gewisse Historie mitbringt. Dadurch würde ich ja sagen, würde auch nicht dein ganzes Konzept über den Haufen geworfen, wenn du da vielleicht mal, sage ich jetzt mal einen 31-Jährigen reinstellst, der halt auch eine gewisse Erfahrung auf internationalen Niveau, das so mit sich bringt. Also ich finde, es ist ganz spannend, daran sieht man, wie stur dann manchmal auch solche Ansätze sind, weil niemand von uns würde ja verlangen, dass da jetzt plötzlich vier 34-Jährige geholt werden müssen. Aber vielleicht wird da eine oder der zweite da schon helfen, um all diesen jungen Talentierten halt auch ein bisschen eine Führung mitzugeben. Aber anscheinend ist es ja gewollt, weil ich glaube, an den finanziellen Mitteln wird es nicht liegen, da eventuell noch einen auch so dazuzuholen, oder?
Eben, absolut richtig. Und man sieht auch das allein am Trainerverschleiß. Denn man hat einmal Risken rausgeschmissen, der eigentlich gute Arbeit leistete, aber einfach daran verzweifelt ist, dass es wieder diese hohe Fluktuation gab, dass ihm auch reingepfuscht wurde in Sachen Aufstellungen, weil man will ja seine Investitionen schützen. Das haben wir schon mal in einer Folge angesprochen. Und man ordnet andere bzw. finanzielle Interessen dem sportlichen Erfolg einfach über. Man weiß, man hat hier diese Anlagen, diese Investitionen. Und im Optimalfall steigen die im Wert und dann werden sie irgendwann verkauft. Und das scheint so ein bisschen wichtiger zu sein.
Ja, und es ist so ein bisschen, glaube ich, auch das Football-Manager-Syndrom. Unter dem so Leute wie wir auch manchmal leiden, weil wir halt so analytisch auf den Sport blicken. In der Theorie sind Spieler zwischen 24 und 27 Jahren in ihrer Prime. Also gerade zu 27, 28 erreichen sie meist den Höhepunkt. Am billigsten kaufen kannst du mit 30. Weil dann psychologisch gesehen bei vielen so eine Transfer ablösen, Schalter sich umsetzt und dann kannst du einen Schnapper machen ab 30 Jahren. Aber in der Praxis ist es eben dann doch so, dass da elf Spieler, zehn Feldspieler in einem Stadion stehen vor Zehntausenden von Menschen, die einen enormen Druck ausgerichtet sind, denen auch gar nicht geholfen ist, dadurch, dass die viel Geld verdienen. Das spielt in solchen Situationen keine Rolle, sondern da kommt halt wirklich Psychologie rein. Und dann kommt nämlich so was wie Führungsspieler mit rein. Nicht jede Führungsspielerdebatte ist immer sinnvoll, weil manchmal liegt es nicht an Führungsspielern. Aber du brauchst sie auf dem Feld eben doch. Eben Spieler, an denen du dich ausrichten kannst. Ich habe neulich mit dem länger über das deutsche Nationalteam gesprochen und auch über deutschen Nachwuchsfußball. Da vielen sehr harte Urteile. Und da ging es aber unter anderem in diese Richtung. Dass das einfach so unterschätzt wird, wie wichtig es ist. Und mir sagen alle ehemaligen Spieler, ja das können nur Spieler beurteilen, die das mal auf dem Feld gesehen haben. Und natürlich würde ich am liebsten sagen, nein, ich sehe es doch in den Daten nicht. Dann kann es nicht da sein. Aber vielleicht muss man es auch einfach respektieren. Wenn eigentlich fast alle ehemaligen Spieler sagen, naja, das ist schon wichtig, dass du jemanden hast, an dem du dich ausrichten kannst. In verschiedenen Situationen. Und man darf nicht vergessen, wie viel Trash-Talk und Nicklichkeiten es trotz allem VLA und so weiter immer noch gibt. Gerade von älteren Spielern gegen jüngeren Spielern. Also ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass Chelsea auch durch seine Kaderstruktur so ein Team ist. Die sind halt auch so leichte Opfer. Da reichen halt zwei sehr erfahrene Spieler in der gegnerischen Mannschaft. Und die trieten in jeder Situation, steigen die ganze Zeit mit den Stollen auf den großen C. Und vielleicht kommt das dann auch noch mit dazu. Wollte ich nur ergänzen.
Absolut. Und man muss ja nur an die Vereinsspitze von Chelsea schauen. Da sitzt Todd Bowley, der hat einen Baseball-Hintergrund. Und das ist ja mit einer der analytischsten Sportarten, die es auf dieser Welt gibt. Und so wird auch dieser Kader oder dieser Verein aufgebaut derzeit. Und das ist eben auch kein Zufall. Und ich finde es auch kein Zufall, Jakob hat gerade die erfahrenen Spieler angesprochen. Und einer davon ist Robert Sanches im Tor. Und der ist ja zugegebenermaßen einfach nicht gut. Er ist ein Unsicherheitsfaktor. Und wenn einer der erfahrenen Spieler ein Unsicherheitsfaktor ist, der bei Standards dermaßen wackelig agiert und unsicher wirkt, das strahlt sich auch auf seine Mitspieler aus. Und es ist kein Zufall, dass Chelsea über eine Milliarde ausgegeben hat, ich glaube Richtung 2 sogar, und aber nicht sein Torhüter neu besetzt hat. Robert Sanches passt nicht zu den Ambitionen dieses Vereins. Und ja, aber warum denn? Weil mit Torhütern in der Regel auch nicht so viel Geld zu machen ist, wie mit Feldspielern. Das ist ja auch kein Zufall. Also, ja.
Ja, irgendwie ein bisschen tröstlich, dass man sich nicht doch alles am Whiteboard zusammenschustern kann. Ja, schauen wir mal, ob sie den Rekord noch brechen. Zwei Platzverweisen sind es noch. Schauen wir doch mal. Und wir schauen auch noch mal nach Frankreich. Und wir machen heute mal was Ungewohntes. Jakob, normalerweise gucken wir oft an die Spitze und in den Keller und suchen uns das Drama, beziehungsweise oft wirft uns die Ligen, werfen uns eigentlich das Drama hin und wir reden dann darüber. Jetzt gehen wir ins Tal der Langeweile oder wie muss ich das verstehen, dass wir jetzt über Stagg-Brest reden, den neuntplatzierten mit neun Siegen, sechs Unentschieden und neun Niederlagen.
Ja, schade, dass sie kein ausgeglichenes Torverhältnis haben.
Aber ganz knapp. 32 geschlossene Tore, 34 Kassierte.
Das ist fast.
Ja, genau. Aber ich finde, es ist doch erwähnenswert. Denn was man bei Stagg-Brest auf jeden Fall anmerken muss, ist, dass ja in den letzten beiden Saisons auf jeden Fall viel über sie gesprochen werden konnte. Denn sie haben sich ja vor zwei Jahren total überraschend für die Champions League qualifiziert, sind da auf einem überragenden dritten Platz gelandet. Und dann haben sie ja in der letzten Saison auch eine absolut fantastische Champions League Runde gespielt, da haben die Gruppen- oder Liga-Phase ja sogar überlebt und sind dann ja in den Playoffs gegen PSG ausgeschieden, das ist dann ja auch relativ krachend. Aber trotzdem war das natürlich für diesen Verein ein Riesenerfolg, denn man muss bei ihnen sagen, sie sind jetzt trotz dieser Ausreißer nach oben schon weiterhin eine der kleineren Mannschaften in der Liga und können sich auch so vom Budget her definitiv in der unteren Tabellenhälfte ansiedeln. Dementsprechend ist da jetzt ein neunter Platz, auch überhaupt kein Drama, zumal man jetzt auch in den letzten Wochen wirklich wieder eine deutlich bessere Form hatte. Man hatte zu Saisonbeginn durchaus ein bisschen Probleme, muss dazu aber auch sagen, dass man im Sommer unglaublich viel Substanz verloren hat. Also man hat mit Pierre Lesmeloux einen der absoluten Führungsspieler verloren, Lyon Brassier, ein Stammspieler in der Innenverteidigung, Marco Bisott, der Stammkeeper, Mady Kamara, einer der kreativen Mittelfeldspieler, dann mit Zima noch eine Laie von Brighton, der auch viele Tore gemacht hatte, Romain Fèvre, der zu Lyon gewechselt ist. Also je nachdem, wie man sieht, mindestens fünf, sechs, sieben Stammspieler verloren vor der Saison. Und dafür ist das halt absolut solide, was sie jetzt auch wieder spielen. Es gab so zu Saisonbeginn ganz kurz mal den Gedanken, ob sie vielleicht unten reinrutschen können. Da standen sie auch eine Zeit lang nicht gut da. Allerdings haben auch die Leistungen auf dem Platz damals schon darauf hingedeutet, dass sie sich eigentlich befreien müssten. Und man muss dazu sagen, dass es im Verein auch eine große Ruhe gibt. Der Trainer Eric Roy ist jetzt seit Anfang 2023 schon im Amt. Also für die heutigen Verhältnisse ja schon eine Ewigkeit, jetzt über drei Jahre da auf jeden Fall. Und ja, leistet auch gute Arbeit. Und was ich gerade noch vergessen habe bei den Abgängen, dass sie die halt auch nicht nennenswert ersetzen, also nicht gleichwertig ersetzen können mit den Möglichkeiten. Die sie haben, das ist ja in Frankreich bei vielen Vereinen so, aber es ist hier definitiv nochmal zu erwähnen. Und ja, das produziert dann halt auch so ein paar ganz schöne Geschichten, dass man zum Beispiel auf der Suche nach einem Ersatz im Tor hatte man erst mal Jetski von Monaco ausgeliehen. Der hat aber wirklich einen ganz, ganz fürchterlichen Saisonstart hingelegt, ist jetzt auf der Bank seitdem und wurde dann durch Grégoire Coudère ersetzt, der jetzt mit 26 plötzlich die Nummer 1 ist, nachdem er eigentlich in seiner ganzen Karriere bisher immer nur 2. oder 3. Kraft war und jetzt so aus dem absoluten Nichts gekommen ist. Der hatte, glaube ich, vor der Saison fünf Erstligaspiele gemacht oder so und spielt jetzt eine super solide Runde, hat, glaube ich, die drittbeste Safe-Percentage in der Liga. Also da hat man das dann auch intern gut gelöst und Einnahme bei Brest, über den ich auf jeden Fall noch sprechen möchte, wo wir vorhin bei Startrennen über Norden gesprochen haben, brauchen wir jetzt den nächsten Ex-Mainzer. Das ist Ludovic Ajorg, der in Frankreich so ein ziemlicher Kult-Spieler ist. Also allein auch aufgrund seiner Statur natürlich irgendwie schon so ein Spieler, der viele fasziniert und der hat auch in der Hinrunde schon gezeigt, dass er wichtig ist für Brest, da allerdings jetzt von den Statistiken ja gar nicht so krass performt, gerade vorm Tor, hatte er durchaus auch seine Probleme. Ich glaube, generell von der Spielweise hat man das ja auch in der Bundesliga gesehen, dass es ein wahnsinniges physisches Monster ist. Also der gewinnt, glaube ich, über 55 Prozent seiner Zweikämpfe, was ja für einen Stürmer eine grandiose Bilanz ist, zieht auch wahnsinnig viele Fouls, hat auch schon acht gelbe Karten bekommen, weil er selber gerne viel foult und halt einfach eine absolute Wucht ist im Sturm. Und jetzt in den letzten Spielen klappt es plötzlich aber auch vor dem Tor wieder. Er hat jetzt in 2.26 fünf Tore und drei Assists gesammelt, ist also einer der formstärksten Spieler oder Stürmer Europas momentan, kann man so sagen, und ist tatsächlich auch mit acht Assists in der ganzen Saison der beste Vorlagengeber in der Ligue 1. Also das ist definitiv auch ein Aspekt, der nicht zu unterschätzen ist und den man jetzt auch bei ihm vielleicht nicht so unbedingt erwartet hätte. Und ein Gedanke, den ich dann noch dabei hatte, dass der wahrscheinlich auch ganz gut zum Spielstil von Urs Fischer passen würde. Also wenn der im Sommer nicht von Mainz weggegangen wäre.
Ja, stimmt, da hättest du die Tits nicht holen müssen.
Genau.
Ja, das ist natürlich, ja, solche Geschichten schreibt ausschließlich der Fußball. Ich versuche gerade hier seine Luftstatistiken in einen europäischen Gesamtkontext zu setzen. Aber ja, heute ist der Wurm drin, die Seite lädt nicht. Ach, guck mal, ja, doch, er ist in den Top 5 Ligen. Liegt er auf Platz 4 bei den geführten Kopfball-Duellen und auch bei den gewonnenen Kopfball-Duellen, das reiche ich gerade nach. Weißt du, wer auf Rang 3 liegt, Jakob?
Philipp Tietz.
Auf Rang 2 übrigens Andre Ilic. Also gut, so viel dazu. Vielleicht hat Urs Fischer dann doch seinen Urs-Fischer-Spieler bekommen, haben wir ja auch schon so erwähnt. Und bei den gewonnenen Kopfball-Duellen ist tatsächlich Ashok auf Rang 3, Philipp Tietz dann nur auf einen Rang 7. Und da liegen, ja, da liegt ein ganzer Kopfball statistisch gesehen dazwischen. Sehr schön, sehr, sehr schön. Stadbrest, hätte ich auch nicht gedacht, dass wir über die nochmal sprechen, aber ich habe es gesehen in der Liste, ich habe es euch ja auch geschrieben. Ich war direkt, direkt on fire. Und das ging mir auch so, Christian, als ich auf dein letztes italienisches Thema geblickt habe, denn on fire trifft sie eigentlich vielleicht auch schon ganz gut. Wir wollen mal über die Roma nochmal sprechen, ist schon eine Weile her. Was hat sich denn bei der Roma so getan? Wer die Tabelle lesen kann, sieht sie auf Platz 4. Logischerweise mit der Meisterschaft nichts mehr zu tun, denn das haben wir ja vorhin schon besprochen. Aber ein bisschen wechselhafter Ergebnisse jetzt zuletzt gehabt. Es ist schon eine ganze Weile her, dass man mal so eine Serie starten konnte.
Ja, haben dich die zwei Stichworte vielleicht ein bisschen geteased, die ich geschickt hatte.
Also eins mehr als das andere.
Also fangen wir mal kurz mit dem Sportlichen an. Gerade am vergangenen Wochenende ist Roma gegen Juve. Also für Roma, wenn es das Derby nicht gäbe, dann ist das Juve-Spiel das emotionalste im Jahr und das hat wirklich geliefert, war ein Riesenspektakel 3-3 eben und das war eine Riesen-Chance, die Roma dann liegen hat lassen. Du hast das gesagt, die Roma liegt immer noch auf Platz 4, also ist auch im Rennen und die Champions League-Ränge sehr gut unterwegs. Aber sie hat bis nicht lange vor Schluss 3-1 geführt gegen eine Juve-Mannschaft, die unter der Woche diese 120 äußerst emotionalen Minuten gegen Galatasaray hinter sich hatte. Und nicht nur emotional, sondern davon auch mehr als eine Stunde in Unterzahl war. Also und Roma hatte, weil die ja erst in der Europa League jetzt im Achtelfinale einstiegen, hatte die ganze Woche Zeit, sich eben rhythmustechnisch auf dieses Spiel vorzubereiten. Und da kam es jetzt schon überraschend, dass sie dann nach diesen 3-1-Führung weiterhin die beste Defensive der Liga, ich glaube mit die beste Defensive Europas, dass sie da spät noch den Ausgleich kassieren. Denn, hätte Roma dieses Spiel gewonnen, hätten sie Juve auf Minus 7 geschickt. Und das ist logisch schon was zu dem Zeitpunkt jetzt, 7 Punkte aufzuholen aus Juvesicht. Die wären dann sicher auch von der Moral her schwer getroffen worden nach diesem Galatasaray aus, nach all den Rückschlägen, die sie zuletzt gelegt haben. Also, das war jetzt eine Riesenchance für die Roma. Trotzdem sind sie ja weiterhin voll mit dabei. Malen wieder getroffen. Malen ist genau der Spieler, den Gasperini gebraucht hat. Ich glaube, er steht bei sechs Toren in sechs Spielen. Also offensiv durch ihn wirklich viel mehr konkret, was da jetzt im letzten Drittel passiert. Das passt. Aber worauf ich eigentlich hinaus wollte, ist, es gibt drum herum ganz interessante Aktualitäten. Nämlich zum einen das Thema Neues Stadion. Neues Stadion ist in Rom auch eines, das schon sehr lang diskutiert wird, wo sehr lang wenig passiert ist. Und jetzt aber ist ein entscheidender Schritt passiert, nämlich die Gemeinde von Rom hat das Stadionprojekt durchgewunken. Also die Fritkens, die Eigentümer, die US-Eigentümer, probieren ja auch schon lange eben sozusagen, den Standort auch durch ein neues Stadion aufzuwerten. Und jetzt hat wirklich vor kurzem die Gemeinde, also dieses Projekt hat jetzt erstmal grünes Licht bekommen. Das heißt, es geht jetzt wirklich in die Richtung, dass vielleicht schon 2030 das neue Stadion dann da stehen könnte. Das war jetzt wirklich ein entscheidender Faktor, weil es war in Rom extrem schwierig überhaupt ein Areal zu finden. Sozusagen viele Projekte sind daran schon gescheitert. Und jetzt ist eben da grünes Licht von der Stadt sozusagen da. Dementsprechend geht das wirklich jetzt in eine heiße Richtung. Ganz spannend, das Stadion soll ungefähr um die 66.000 Zuschauer Platz bieten. Und was ich mich schon besonders freue, es soll eine der größten Kurven Europas sein, mit 23.000 Mann und Frauen sozusagen in der Kurve. Und wer die Roma-Kurve kennt, jetzt schon im Olympico, ich würde sagen, eine der emotionalsten in ganz Europa. Also ich glaube, da haben sie die richtige Idee verfolgt sozusagen, auch dieses Kurven, die Sache, die Kurve aufzuwerten sozusagen, wird bei dem neuen Stadionprojekt da definitiv mitgegangen. Und also das würde ich mal sagen, eine schöne Nachricht, auch wirklich zeigt eben auch, dass die Fritkins, eben die Eigentümer da auch, wir hatten es ja vorhin bei Atalanta, dass es da nicht nur darum geht, Geld in den Kader zu stecken, sondern schon auch den ganzen Standort eben sozusagen, ja im Idealfall auf ein neues Niveau zu heben. Und die zweite Personalie, da werden jetzt logisch ein paar besonders drauf hören und ja, warum auch nicht, Francesco Totti.
Das war das zweite Stichwort. Ich gebe es dir zu. Standort fand ich schon ganz interessant, habe auch gleich noch eine Frage zu, aber jetzt sag mir, was mit Totti ist.
Genau. Ja, bei Totti war ja auch klar vor Jahren, also er hat ja schon mal eine kurze Funktion gehabt bei Palotta. Das war noch der erste US-amerikanische Eigentümer. Das war dann aber relativ schnell zu Ende, weil er mehr oder weniger da nur so eine Grußfunktion hatte, so eine Vertretungsfunktion, und das wollte er nicht. Und hat sich dann auch total zurückgezogen, hat aber damals schon gesagt, logisch, die Roma ist weiterhin in meinem Herzen und wer weiß, wenn mal neue Eigentümer da sind, dann reden wir wieder von neuen. Und jetzt ist es wirklich, es schaut sehr konkret aus, es gab in den letzten Monaten schon immer wieder mal so kleine Momente. Francesco Totti war plötzlich bei einem Roma-Heimspiel, das war schon ein erstes Signal, aber es gab es wirklich lange nicht mehr. Und sobald Totti im Stadion ist, dann geht in Romdorf-Lufunk auf 120 sozusagen. Und jetzt hatten wir vergangene Woche das erste offizielle Treffen zwischen Gasperini und Totti. Also es liegt immer näher, dass Totti jetzt wirklich wieder in den Club zurückkehrt. Die Frage ist eigentlich nur noch, in welcher Funktion. Gasperini hat sich jetzt auch schon öffentlich dazu geäußert, begrüßt das sehr. Und anscheinend was ganz spannend ist, es geht wohl darum, dass er wirklich auch nicht nur eine institutionelle Funktion übernimmt, sondern wirklich auch was sozusagen Manager-mäßiges. Es steht im Raum, dass er vielleicht Sportdirektor wird, also jetzt nicht so eine übergeordnete Figur, also auch wirklich was Transfer-Stunt betrifft, dass er da mitredet. Zur Erinnerung, Totti war die letzten Jahre, hat auch selbst eine Spieloperatoragentur gegründet, hat jetzt auch relativ viel in dem Segment gemacht, gerade mit jungen Spielern. Und es scheint also jetzt wirklich auf dem Weg zu sein, dass die Rückkehr zu Totti, zu Roma auch in einer aktiven und relativ starken Position kurz vorm Abschluss steht. Und ja, das befeuert logischerweise in Rom und im Roma-Ambiente alles.
Ja, also da ist jetzt auf jeden Fall Energie drauf. Aber um nochmal kurz auf das Stadion zurückzukommen, das wäre ja am selben Standort. Ersetzt es dann das Stadio Olimpico?
Nein, nein, nein, es ist. Darum ging es eben. Es ging anders als bei San Siro in Mailand. Das Olimpico ist ja auch in diesem ganz speziellen Ambiente. Da ist ja auch Foro Italico, wo zum Beispiel das Tennis-TP-Turnier stattfindet. Das ist ja wirklich dieser Olympiapereich, der ist sicherlich auch geschützt. Es ging immer darum, das Stadion auch an einem neuen Ort in Rom ausfindig zu machen. Die Gegend heißt jetzt Pietralta. Fragt mich jetzt bitte nicht, wo genau geografisch das in Rom dieser Ecke ist. Aber es geht nicht darum, das Olympico neu zu machen. Es wird ein völlig neues, komplettes Stadion in einem neuen Areal.
Und dann auch nur für die Roma.
Genau, nur für die Roma. Die Lazio hat zum Beispiel auch Stadion-Gedanken. Nicht nur Gedanken. Da geht es auch darum, einen idealen Platz zu finden. Also genau, es wird darauf auslaufen, dass es irgendwann vielleicht, falls Lazio es ausschafft, dann wirklich auch zwei Stadionen jeweils für das eine Team in Rom gibt.
Also man spricht aktuell von 1,5 Milliarden Baukosten. Aber wenn das alles kommt, dann ist es jetzt erstmal nur der erste wichtige Schritt gegangen. Da werden wir da eh noch häufig genug drüber sprechen. Und ich sage euch, und das kommt ja ganz eindeutig vor allem aus Deutschland, dieses Orientieren an vielen Stehplätzen. Also dass du eben versuchst, so eine einheitliche Kurve zu schaffen. Das meine ich jetzt komplett hierher. Stehplätze gibt es natürlich auch woanders. Aber dass du Stadien so konzipierst, alle haben erst versucht, die gelbe Wand zu imitieren. Und daher kommt das. Und ich sage euch, es wird in spätestens– was haben wir jetzt 2026? Also spätestens 2030, wenn angeblich der Stadion eröffnet wird, ich bin gespannt, dann wird es auch Stehplätze in UEFA-Wettbewerben geben. Es gibt keine Begründung mehr dafür. Es kommt alles nur von Heysel und so schrecklich Heysel war. Aber es wird kommen und mit jedem Stadion, das gebaut wird, mit eben so vielen Stehplätzen, wird das, glaube ich, wahrscheinlicher. Chris möchte noch was sagen.
Ja, nur dazu, in England wird jetzt auch wieder vermehrt auf Safe Standing geachtet. Also da kommt es jetzt auch allmählich zurück. Und da ist man ja auch am gebrannt marksten.
Genau. Und ja, und das ist eben einfach eine andere Situation jetzt. Plus du baust ja inzwischen auch Stehplatztribünen anders als noch früher. Also wenn ihr euch mal anguckt, wie Wellenbrecher und so weiter verteilt sind, wie anders Mundlöcher jetzt meistens konzipiert sind, dass es eben nicht mal so gewisse Effekte gibt, die es bei alten Stadien manchmal noch gab. Also ja, freue ich mich schon drauf, wenn wir das irgendwann auch mal wieder in UEFA-Wettbewerben haben. Stehplätze. Irgendwann wird die UEFA checken, aber wir können jetzt nicht nochmal mehr Teams reinholen in Champions League, um noch mehr Spiele zu machen. Und dann werden sie an solche Soft-Faktoren, an solche weichen Faktoren werden sie rangehen. Wir werden sagen, wäre es nicht geil, wenn wir irgendwie so schöne Bilder hätten wie in anderen. Natürlich Pyrro immer noch schlimm, schlimm schon schlimm, aber Stehplätze wollen wir jetzt haben. Naja, gut, aber das führt jetzt ein bisschen weit. Also ich bin absolut elektrisiert, Christian. Ich freue mich da so auf beides, also sowohl Stadion als auch Totti.
Das hat beides Potenzial, ja, definitiv.
Aber wirklich, es ist einfach einer der grandiosesten Fußballspieler, die ich in meinen Lebzeiten halt erlebt habe. Und zwar quasi so als Gesamtkonstrukt. Und gar nicht nur sportlich, sondern einfach so das Gesamtding, ja. Gut, aber bevor ich jetzt...
Nee, aber deswegen auch noch ein letzter Satz dazu. Es ist schon besonders spannend, weil logisch die Figur Totti, die wird ja auch im Ausland oft so wahrgenommen. Ich glaube, als Spieler können sich relativ viele darauf einigen. Aber logisch war schon auch die Frage danach, was ist er denn zu leisten im Stande? Also was kann er auch so einem Club sozusagen jetzt wirklich geben, außer seinem Namen und seinem Gesicht? Und deswegen ist das jetzt, glaube ich, wird es auch für ihn, wenn es wirklich in die Richtung geht, dass er da eine aktive Rolle bekommt, ist das jetzt schon für ihn auch sowohl eine Riesenchance, aber sicherlich auch, er muss dann auch beweisen, dass er sowas auch ausführen kann, weil ja, vielleicht hat er nicht oft die Chance bekommen, vielleicht hat er sie sich auch manchmal hin und wieder auch ein bisschen selbst zunichte gemacht. Also das wäre jetzt wirklich sowohl Chance als auch sicherlich auch ein gewisses Risiko. Kann Francesco Totti eben neben seinem Namen, neben seinem Gesicht auch inhaltlich seinem Herzensverein was geben. Also deswegen, da werden wir dranbleiben.
Wir schauen es uns auf jeden Fall genau an. Und dann wollen wir auch mal indirekt auf Manchester United blicken, Chris. Denn das haben ja die Hörerinnen und Hörer sicherlich mitbekommen. Die hatten jetzt eine irre ungeschlagen Serie. Wir haben ja hier auch schon mal thematisiert, bzw. ich glaube, wir haben es thematisiert, ob da vielleicht sogar mal fünf Siege in Folge klappen und der Friseur angerufen werden muss. Dem ist jetzt nicht so gekommen. Man hat jetzt auch gegen Newcastle trotz Überzahl verloren, jetzt unmittelbar vor dieser Sendung. Aber dennoch steht Manchester United viel, viel besser da als noch vor einigen Wochen. Man liegt auf Rang 3 in der Premier League. Und es gibt vor allem einen Spieler, der läuft gerade heiß, so wie ich beim Thema Roma und Totti. Wer ist es und warum?
Genau, Benjamin Cesco. Ich dachte, nachdem man schon zu genüge über Voltemade, RKTK etc. gesprochen hat, lohnt es sich vielleicht auch, über Cesco zu reden und wie er sich in der Premier League so schlägt. Du hast es bereits gesagt, seitdem Carrick da ist und United wieder in die Spur gekommen ist, ist auch Cesco durchgestartet. Sieben Tore in den letzten zehn Spielen. Kein Premier League-Spieler hat in englischen Wettbewerben in diesem Jahr mehr Tore erzielt. Und davor waren es eben zwei Tore in 16. Da sieht man schon die Wände. Davor gab es Knieprobleme, Anpassungsprobleme, Amorins-Fußballprobleme und jetzt startet er durch. Und man muss auch sagen, es hat sich schon lange angedeutet. Also selbst in den schlechten Phasen von Man United ist Cesco aufgefallen durch klasse Bewegungen, super Laufwege. Also man kennt ja seine Attribute auch aus der Bundesliga. Es war, glaube ich, auch immer nur eine Frage, ob er wirklich dieser geschliffene Spieler werden kann, weil, wie gesagt, er ein ungeschliffener Diamant gewesen, hohe Attribute, alles da, alles, er hat alles, was ein Stürmer braucht, die Athletik, die Schnelligkeit, Kopfballstärke, also all das ist da. Und ich finde es ziemlich beachtlich, was er auch an Arbeitsethos besitzt. Denn ich weiß nicht, ob die Geschichte von Leipzig bekannt ist, als ihm sogar dieses Armbändchen für den Fitnessraum abgenommen wurde, weil er es fast schon übertrieben hat. Dazu hat er jetzt bei Man United, da gab es eine kurze 13-tägige Pause während der Saison, weil man aus den Wettbewerben ausgeschieden war. Da waren die Spieler teilweise in Dubai. Und Sesko hat die Zeit genutzt, um da bei einem Spezial-Trainingsprogramm teilzunehmen und hat wirklich an jedem Tag trainiert. Und er hat daheim auch noch so einen LED-Reflex-Trainer, ein Fußballfeld, ein Virtual Reality Headset. Also er investiert unfassbar viel. Und da ist es auch schön zu sehen, dass die Arbeit sich lohnt. Und ja, also aktuell scheint diese Wette, die Man United im Sommer aufgenommen hat, für 77 Millionen tatsächlich aufzugehen. Denn wenn er wirklich sein Potenzial erfüllt, dann wird er diese Summe auf jeden Fall wert sein.
Mir hat jemals, als damals Benjamin Sesko zu Leipzig gewechselt ist, da hat mir jemand gesagt aus der Bundesliga, wenn der gesund bleibt, dann wird es ein Top-5-Stürmer Europas. Und alles, was du jetzt sagst, zahlt darauf ein, die Quote zahlt darauf ein und das Alter. 22 Jahre ist er ja erst jung. Das ist ja irre. Und wie der es geschafft hat, das war für mich so das größte Fragezeichen, wie schnell bekommt er die Athletik hin, um sich eben in der halt viel athletischeren Premier League durchzusetzen. Und zugegeben, ich habe jetzt vor allem die Tore gesehen, habe jetzt nicht spielüber 90 Minuten gesehen. Aber da hatte ich den Eindruck, es ist kein Problem. Alles, was du so erzählst, klingt auch danach.
Ja, absolut. Also da gab es ja diesen einen Sprint gegen Everton war es, glaube ich, wo er wirklich irre schnell über das gesamte Feld durchgestartet ist und abgeschlossen hat. Jetzt gegen Crystal Palace, ein Kopfballtor, bei dem er wirklich in der Luft steht. Also man sieht, die Tore fallen unterschiedlich. Und das einzige Fragezeichen war ja auch teilweise ein bisschen der Abschluss, nicht wegen der Technik, sondern ich glaube einfach, weil er noch nicht so die Coolness hatte vom Tor. Und wenn du jetzt die Tore siehst, ist es eiskalt mit einer irren Geschwindigkeit ins Netz befördert. Also das funktioniert auch allmählich. Also ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass er sein Potenzial wirklich jetzt erfüllen wird, wenn es so weitergeht.
Ja und auch da wieder ganz kurz aus Italien. Also das Paket haben sie auch in Italien sehr gesehen. Ich weiß zum Beispiel, dass Milan alles probiert hat. Aber dann war klar, als die Premier League-Summen im Spiel waren, war klar, dass man da nicht mitgehen kann. Aber Milan hat den auch schon in dem Jahr davor schon auf dem Zettel gehabt. Da gab es auch schon Überlegungen. Ja, am Ende, klar, gegen die Finanzmacht aus der Premier League war da nichts zu holen. Aber das Paket war definitiv auch bei den großen Italienern absolut schon weit oben auf dem Zettel. Und schön, dass das anscheinend in die Richtung auch geht. Und wie ihr sagt, also 22 ist schon krass, finde ich. Gerade bei so einem Spielertyp, so einem Neuner, also da kann noch sehr viel kommen. Ich glaube, wir sind uns alle einig, wenn der gesund bleibt.
Es gibt aber noch ein Aber beziehungsweise eine Frage, die ich habe, Chris. Also jetzt hat er vier Tore in den letzten sechs Spielen zum Beispiel gemacht, aber hat auch nur in einem Spiel jetzt eben gegen Newcastle über 90 Minuten gespielt. Warum wird er derzeit nur eingewechselt?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Gegen Man City saß sogar das ganze Spiel auf der Bank. Und ab da kam er dann mehr zum Einsatz. Ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass es auch ein bisschen an der Ausrichtung von Michael Carrick liegt, denn man ist zwar wieder an die Spur gekommen, aber wenn man sich die Spiele ansieht, so unfassbar überzeugend war das jetzt nicht unbedingt. United ist eher wieder an die Spur gekommen, weil man sich ein bisschen wieder auf die Basics fokussiert hat, was Amorim einfach komplett das Gegenteil gemacht hat, viel zu verkopft. Und es ging halt, glaube ich, mehr um eine defensive Grundausrichtung, um gut in Konton zu sein und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass es ein bisschen an der Defensivarbeit liegt.
Okay, wir werden wir weiter beobachten, aber das wird natürlich in Zukunft die Diskussion werden. Man muss natürlich auch sagen, man hat da sehr unterschiedliche Spielerprofile. Also, Mateusz Kunja spielt ja quasi nominell die Spitze in den Spielen, in denen Cescun nicht auftritt. Also, muss jetzt, glaube ich, nicht viel zu sagen, dass die unterschiedliche Spieler sind, das weiß man. Und die interpretieren ihre Rolle auch anders. Und deswegen, vielleicht muss da Kerik auch noch, also ich glaube, er passt manchmal auch auf die Gegner an. Zumindest sieht es für mich so aus, wenn ich mir jetzt einfach nur die Startaufstellungen angucke. Und ja, aber das ist eben, macht es ja eigentlich noch krasser, dass Cescun trotzdem so viele Tore geholt hat, mit eben noch weniger Spielzeit. Also, behaltet den Namen im Hinterkopf, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und ich kannte die Leipzig-Geschichte noch nicht mit dem Fitness-Armbändchen. Sehr, sehr schön. Dann blicken wir auch nochmal in die Ligue 1, Jakob. Denn da gibt es ja noch eine große Titelfrage, die nicht geklärt ist. Meisterschaft haben wir ja vorhin schon im Grunde zugemacht, auch wenn es offiziell noch nicht so ist. Aber der viel, viel spannendere Titel ist ja ein anderer.
Genau. Die Coupe de France ist nämlich noch offen. Da läuft jetzt– also nicht jetzt, während wir aufnehmen, aber gerade unter dieser Woche läuft– laufen die Viertelfinals. Drei von vier sind durch. Und wir hatten, glaube ich, ganz kurz das vor ein paar Wochen schon mal angerissen, dass ja Paris schon ausgeschieden ist. Auch schon vor zwei Runden damals ja gegen den Stadtrivalen Paris FC. Und somit steht hier auch fest, dass PSG nicht die dritte Coupe de France in Folge gewinnen wird. Ich finde, die Coupe de France ist schon so ein ganz besonderer Wettbewerb. Es macht mir immer riesig Spaß, das zu verfolgen. Auch wenn jetzt, seitdem die Qatar in Paris investiert hat, schon die Dominanz von PSG relativ groß ist. Man hat jetzt von den letzten 11 Ausgaben acht gewonnen. Allerdings immerhin von in den letzten vier Jahren nur zweimal. Es gab dann auch zwei, ich glaube, man kann es so sagen echte Überraschungssieger. Es war dann nicht so, wie es in Deutschland häufig ist, dass dann eines der nächstgrößeren Teams den Titel abgreift. Sondern es war dann 21-22 Nont und 22-23 Toulouse. Also zwei Teams, die jetzt eigentlich auch in der Tabelle wirklich nicht, zumindest nicht um die Champions League-Plätze mitspielen in den letzten Jahren. Und generell, es, finde ich, gibt sehr, sehr viele Überraschungen. Wir hatten zum Beispiel im letzten Jahr ein verrücktes Halbfinale. Da war ein Viertligist, ein Zweitligist und mit Stade Rennes ein Team, was ja später auch abgestiegen ist aus der Ligue 1 im Halbfinale. Und dann waren in den vorherigen Runden extrem viele Erstligisten auch gegen unterklassige Teams ausgeschieden. Und das ist auch tatsächlich jetzt in Frankreich eher die Regel als die Ausnahme. Also es gibt jetzt in den letzten 20 Jahren gab es zahlreiche Dritt-, Viert-, Fünftligisten, die es sogar teilweise bis ins Finale geschafft haben in der Coupe de France. Und das ist dann schon etwas, was den Pokal, glaube ich, von vielen anderen Pokalen in den anderen Ländern auch unterscheidet. Dass da wirklich diese Sensationsdichte relativ hoch ist und dass die unterklassigen Teams dann auch teils wirklich extrem weit schaffen können. Das ist in dieser Saison jetzt anders. Man hat zwar den großen Favoriten raus, allerdings hat man im Halbfinale jetzt auch nur Erstligisten und hatte auch schon im Viertelfinale mit Stadranz nur ein Team aus der zweiten Liga, die aber auch da oben mitspielen. Also das war jetzt nicht so ungewöhnlich, was aber durchaus bemerkenswert ist, dass jetzt auch von den verbliebenen Teams eigentlich fast alle sehr, sehr lange auf einen Titel warten. Man hatte jetzt gestern die Situation, dass es zwei Spiele gab, die erst im Elfmeterschießen entschieden wurden. Einmal hat es Nizza gegen Lorient weitergekommen und dann ist Toulouse gegen Marseille weitergekommen. Und Toulouse ist jetzt auch das einzige Team, das wirklich in der kürzeren Vergangenheit einen von den nennenswerten Titeln gewonnen hat. Man hat mit Straßburg noch den anderen schon feststehenden Halbfinalisten, die am 18.19. immerhin mal den Liga-Pokal gewonnen, der allerdings natürlich auch eine etwas kleinere Rolle spielt. Auch wenn der damals in Frankreich noch eigentlich wieder Pokal ausgetragen wurde. Es war nicht so, dass dann nur zwei, drei Teams gegeneinander gespielt haben, sondern es war schon auch ein bisschen wie der League Cup in England. Den gibt es allerdings auch jetzt nicht mehr. Und der echte Pokalsieg bei Straßburg ist jetzt auch schon über 20 Jahre her. Und genau, Nizza, die jetzt auch fürs Halbfinale qualifiziert sind, haben letztmals 96, 97 den Pokal gewonnen. Also auch da ist eine lange Titellosigkeit. Wir hatten kurz darüber gesprochen, dass ja eigentlich Marseille sich diesen Wettbewerb jetzt ausgeguckt hatte, um die Titelflaute zu beenden. Das hat jetzt mit dem Aus gestern auch nicht geklappt. Und heute Abend spielen noch Lyon und Lens gegeneinander. Auf der einen Seite Lyon, die ja in den Nullerjahren die riesige Dominanz hatten, wo sie Titel um Titel geholt haben. Jetzt aber auch seit ja 12.13, wo sie den Supercup gewonnen haben und 11.12, wo sie den Pokal gewonnen haben, titellos sind. Und Lens, die natürlich, wenn es jetzt tatsächlich nicht für die Meisterschaft reichen sollte, zumindest den Pokal holen könnten. Und auch die haben den Pokal tatsächlich noch nie gewonnen, haben letztes Mal 97, 98 die Meisterschaft geholt und dann im Jahr darauf den Liga-Pokal. Also es wird, außer es wird to lose. Und selbst da wäre es auch eine große Überraschung, weil die sind auch im Mittelfeld der Liga. Wird es auf jeden Fall einen Titelträger geben, der dann eine lange Titellosigkeit beenden kann.
Ach, sehr schön. Spielt eure Pokale nicht in Hin- und Rückspiel. Einfach nur ein Spiel. Dann ist sowas leichter.
Und keine Verlängerung.
Ach ja, stimmt. Genau deswegen geht es so oft ins Elfmeterschießen. Das hatte ich gerade schon wieder vergessen. Ja, okay. Und das hat man wahrscheinlich in Marseille, hat man das durch zur Kenntnis genommen, das verlorene Elfmeterschießen.
Total, ja. Vor allem, weil man auch schon wieder zweimal geführt hat und schon wieder zu Hause zwei Gegentore kassiert hat. Also super. Javi Bey ist jetzt auch mit zwei verschiedenen Teams aus dem Pokal ausgeschieden, nachdem er ja auch für das Aus von Startrennen verantwortlich war. Ich glaube, das gab es auch für ein League-Ein-Team noch nie tatsächlich.
Oh man, aber es ist schön zu sehen, dass es überall dann doch noch irgendwie spannende Wettbewerbe gibt. Man kann es wirklich nur weiterempfehlen. Also den Coupe de France, wenn er das jetzt hier noch am Donnerstag hört, um 21.10 Uhr am heutigen Donnerstag, den 5.3., wird eben zwischen Lyon und Lens gespielt. Wo man es sehen kann, weiß ich gerade nicht, aber irgendwie kriegt man es ja. Na klar, wäre ich jetzt auch drauf gekommen, wenn ich mir das hier dran lasse. Was weiß denn ich? Was ich weiß, ist, dass das wirklich eine sehr, sehr schöne Folge war. Mir hat es besonders Spaß gemacht, dass wir so ein bisschen Luft hatten, auch wirklich Diskussionen laufen zu lassen. Das war wirklich, wirklich schön. Ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank an Christian Bernhard, an Jakob Haffke und an Chris McCarthy. Danke euch dreien.
Danke schön.
Danke dir.
Und ich danke natürlich auch euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, denn ihr wisst ja, ihr macht alles hier möglich im Rasenfunk. Der Rasenfunk ist frei von Werbung, frei von Sponsoren und auch frei von einer Paywall. Gerade so eine Sendung hier, wie so eine klassische Paywall-Sendung eigentlich. Aber das wollen wir nicht, denn wir wollen, dass alle den Zugriff haben auf alles, was wir jemals gemacht haben. Also das geht ja auch viele, viele Jahre jetzt schon zurück. Wie ist das möglich? Über nette Menschen, die uns freiwillig, ohne dass es irgendeinen Zwang gibt, unterstützen und das finanziell. Ihr findet in der Video- und der Podcast-Beschreibung, wie das geht. Es dauert auch wirklich nicht lange. Inzwischen haben wir auf unserer Homepage sogar einen dieser schicken QR-Codes. Da müsst ihr nur abscannen und dann könnt ihr uns einen Dauerauftrag einrichten oder eine Einmal-Überweisung zukommen lassen. Also schaut euch das sehr gerne an, wenn euch Sendungen wie diese hier gefallen haben. Verfolgt uns gerne auch in unseren anderen Feeds. Und in der Sendung möchte ich mich bedanken bei Jörg G7, bei Kicker's Emden Maniac, also wenn der nicht die Ligatour hört, dann weiß ich auch nicht, bei Sebastian 96 und bei Lest 1893. Ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank für eure Unterstützung. Und dann habe ich für alle Ligatour-Afficionados draußen noch einen weiteren Podcast-Tipp. Denn ihr könnt euch sehr gerne das Tribüning-Gespräch anhören, das ich aufgezeichnet habe am vorgestrigen Dienstag. Und zwar mit den beiden Hebelbrüdern. Und die sollten euch ein Begriff sein. Die haben ein Buch über sich schreiben lassen. Wir reden aber auch viel darüber, wie sie ihren Job interpretieren. Und da ich weiß, dass ihr Uli und Jogi mögt, sage ich, ihr werdet auch dieses Tribüning-Gespräch lieben. In diesem Sinne, hört es euch gerne an. Bleibt gesund, bis bald, ciao!
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen.
Vielen Dank!